Uh,
oh wow.
I trust this guy.
You just sense it when it happened.
He tells me he gives me a countdown.
Oh,
okay.
I see.
Gives me countdown and then he does
this.
Oh,
that's cool.
I'm trying to bring that back.
When you see,
see people and you like him,
you give him the double double guns.
It's a hard,
hard sell these days.
Why?
Everybody's scared of guns.
Oh,
you're saying it's funny.
You know,
like if the odds of you doing it,
you have to do it within a certain
amount of time from a mass shooting.
Right?
Like you couldn't do it the day of.
I couldn't be like a columbine.
You like dunk.
Wow.
He's so morose.
We're fucked up.
Sense of humor that guy's got,
he's making fun day.
How could you,
why is that funny to him?
That is not fine.
I can't believe you're fucking doing
those signs to,
can I sit down and talk to you for a
second bro?
Don't you think it's time?
It's time to really talk about using
these guns.
Gestures because honestly,
I know it's not really hurting anybody,
but we have to pay respect to the people
who've lost their lives in these
terrible weapons and I just think we
should remove it for rails.
You just show me the replacement Emoji.
Apple has a new Emoji.
They got rid of the pistol and they put,
they turn it into a water gun.
I'll tell you,
man,
every time I looked at that whole pistol
Emoji,
and this is no joke,
when I used to look at it,
it just filled me with a desire to go
shoot up a fucking shopping mall.
That Emoji,
so I'm glad they got rid of it.
Me.
It made me want to go back to the old
west.
I wanted to be like a cowboy.
Maybe if they had shopped,
wait,
wait.
Apple adds more gender diverse emojis in
Ios 10 please explain to us Google with
new Emoji to find the Waterpik and this
is what came up first.
Yeah.
How dare you.
How dare you bring this up.
100 new and redesigned emoji characters,
including no more guns,
but you know,
female,
female athletes.
Okay.
That's cool.
Cool.
Oh,
so okay.
Gender diverse.
All right,
well we'll do high for the show.
I was thinking gender neutral.
Gender diversity does buttes.
Those are some sweet new emojis.
That's actually cool.
Nothing wrong with that.
Emojis are weird.
It's weird.
One like friends start sending you
emojis because like for the longest time
guys never sent Emoji.
No Way.
And now it's happening.
I love him man.
What a useful fucking thing.
That animated gifs and the emojis praise
God and heaven.
It's so great.
It saves so much time.
It gets across so much more.
Language is so limited,
man.
We have to like,
it really is.
I think we're going to hieroglyphs what
do you eventually,
yeah,
I think that's what these emojis are.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
I think there are a modern version of
hieroglyphs.
That's right.
Yeah.
They articulate so much,
you know,
it's like very efficient form of
language.
It just needs to get a little deeper so
that the emojis are animated a little
bit so that they can,
you can sort of tune in the Emoji to
this specific thing you're trying to
convey to somebody instead of just the
smiley face,
which they have in the Apple Watch.
You can like kind of like,
you can control it a little bit.
The Smiley face Emoji.
You just need to be able to dial it in a
little bit more.
Do you think by limiting like by keeping
it more open ended,
right.
Like instead of having a bunch of like
descriptives nouns and verbs and things
like that instead of that having more of
an open ended idea,
like a smiley face.
Yeah,
Uh,
and then knuckles,
which is like,
Yo give me some knuckles,
I'll see you later.
You know what I mean?
Like you can kind of like keep it in
this weird non undefined stay.
Like we both know what it is but it's
not,
it's not written anywhere.
Yeah.
And it relieves you of having to like
compose some sentence.
Do I use an exclamation mark here?
Should I use a comma?
What do I need to say?
I just want to get,
I'm going to see him in like 20 minutes.
It's way easier to do like an alien
head,
a thumbs up,
and a smiley face that says everything.
It's fun to,
it's fun when someone sends you like an
alien head and then a pile of shit,
you know,
like what,
how do I decide?
But yeah,
it's a,
it's such a,
that's such a wonderful emerging
language.
It just needs to get animated.
And you know,
the animated gifts are amazing for
really going deep into how you're
feeling because some of them are
awesome.
Yeah,
they're fantastic.
They're fantastic.
It's so fun to send those things,
man.
Yeah,
it's memes.
I mean like Internet memes.
Really funny ones are really like a new
kind of comedy.
Yeah.
It's like a short,
it's like these are jokes.
He's like punchlines,
but sometimes better than someone saying
anything because you're seeing it.
Right.
Like a Thomson,
Aurora had one on his page today,
uh,
with this face and a,
it's a,
this is a popular one that keeps going
around.
Uh,
when you nut,
but she keeps sucking look at Thompson
hours.
I mean,
this is in no way saying that he
invented this because this is,
I think he'd be the first admit he's,
he's piggy backing on a meme that we all
know.
Right?
Right.
I don't know who wrote that first meme
when you know,
and she keeps looking at his face,
look at his face.
Oh my God.
It's hilarious.
But this,
um,
this meme when you nut and she keeps
sucking,
there's like fucking
hundreds of them.
Have you seen them?
Like just google when you not and she
keeps sucking and then go to images and
you'd be like,
oh my God,
there's so many.
Wow,
dude,
there's hundreds of these.
Wow.
I would like to know the percentage.
I'd like to know the percentage of
people who have created these that have
never gotten a blow job.
I wonder what it is like 15 20%.
It's a good one.
It's superman was a good one.
It's funny because you can put that on
phases all throughout history,
you know,
and there's also versions of it,
how you be when you bust.
But she keeps sucking or she's still
sucking.
This guy's playing the cello when you
finish,
but she keeps sucking.
He did so many of them.
That might be like one of the most
persistent jokes currently on the
Internet.
Oh my.
Yeah
guys.
A bill cosby one.
Oh look,
they've got the one at the Indian guy
died during a speech.
Had a stroke.
What?
Yeah.
That guy just died.
Oh,
I saw them on the Internet.
Is that what happened?
Yeah,
he had,
he had a stroke as he was speaking.
Yes.
Oh,
see,
look.
You can look right before and that will
in the related images.
Wow.
It's incredible.
Right before in the universe.
Out of the universe and out.
He died right there.
Yeah.
I think,
well,
I mean it depends on how you define
death.
Yup.
Bye.
Outta here.
The bezdecki crazy best death.
That's one of the best deaths you're
witnessing.
Like he said,
he just made a great point that he
thinks it's kind of funny and then he
dies.
God,
wow.
Bless it.
Exit from this incarnation.
That is a crazy image.
Yeah.
Um,
who is that guy?
Do you know who he is?
Nope.
Hmm.
How'd you find him,
Jamie?
Just from the stack.
Yeah.
That's a crazy story.
Who like,
it's so funny,
when he died he guaranteed did not think
you would land in a,
when you not in chic.
It keeps me in the power of his death
that he would shatter into a million
things.
And one of them is a meme.
Well,
here's the thing about these memes.
There's guys who are like meme artists
and they're really,
really funny.
And then there's also people that,
that
they kinda like Carlos man see a memes.
Oh yeah,
no,
I probably should stop using that guys
name like that.
It's rude,
but it's really sad as everyone knows
that that means.
Yeah.
When you,
there was just someone just tweeted
that,
uh,
there's a,
there's a product in the UK that stole
Mitch Hedberg Joke.
It's a product that has just written in
the bag.
His joke,
like when you want to eat rice ice,
when you want to eat 2000 of the same
things or whatever.
They like just pop that right in the
back.
But they didn't credit him.
They credited the name of their mascot
for the company.
Well,
let's,
it's a problem with memes because people
do it all the time.
Like there's people that have pages
where they're all their memes or someone
else's that they don't give credit for,
right.
And then they get caught and then they
have to start re,
you know,
retweeting stuff.
But sometimes you retweet the wrong
person,
know you,
you retweet someone who just copied it
from somebody else.
Yeah.
I've had that happen more than once.
You don't know,
but they're funny.
So it's like what do you do?
Do you just retweet it because you think
it's funny and you laugh or should you
hold onto it until you can find
ownership of the meme?
Yeah,
I mean,
I took good question,
right?
I think if you can give credit,
give credit,
but if we spend too much time getting
caught up in meme distribution,
then we're going to lose what is so
beautiful about the thing,
which is that I create some meme,
upload it to the Internet and it either
like just molders on injure or whatever,
or it just scatters and a trillion
pieces everywhere.
There's something really cool and
beautiful in that.
And I don't think meme transmitters are,
are thieves.
Mostly there's just a few scumbags who
take people shit and don't credit them
and then they get punished.
Usually they get punished by the
Internet.
Well severely.
Absolutely.
But there have been a bunch of people
that have done it and they're now make
money off of it.
Yeah.
That,
that's where it gets weird because
there's a bunch of people that are just
really funny and maybe they're
introverts and they never were really
good at cracking jokes socially cause
they're,
they're nervous,
but they're funny.
They have a funny mine.
Yes.
And so this is a form of joke writing
and joke telling.
Yeah,
a really good one too.
So somebody had to be the first person
to come up with when she,
you know when you come.
But she keeps sucking.
Someone has to be.
So this is like this massive plagiarism
that we're all laughing at.
Yeah.
But you know,
is that what it is?
I don't think,
I mean how do you like that guy deserves
credit cause he is funny.
Right?
The guy who invented it burst.
That's a funny guy.
Like that was a good idea.
It's funny he does.
He definitely deserves credit for it.
So I know what you're saying.
But then eventually you're going to
like,
I guess you can watermark your meme,
right?
He could have watermark that you see
that sometimes but eventually the
watermark is going to get taken off
cause you know your people were putting
in new picks.
Well yeah,
I mean live.
The second one is there's hundreds of
different images.
So like you could never watermark that.
And what's very funny about it is
they'll take the word com for example,
there was a first human who for whatever
reason decided to call his ejaculations
calm.
He just decided on who the fuck was that
guy.
There is first.
That's a huge point because it's
universal.
It's universal.
Yeah.
How do you trace it back?
I mean,
every single word that a human being
uses,
theoretically you could follow it
backwards through time in the same way
you follow any organic life form you
can,
it's called atomology.
You can look at the weird a way that
language mutates over time and you know
that it's somewhere way,
way back in the back of the line,
there had to be somebody who's like,
we'll call it a mountain or whatever.
The precursor term for mountain was
somebody who was like,
it's a hood that someone does that,
right?
It has to,
has to someone.
So
isn't that the idea that one point in
time we all had a universal language,
but it became a giant issue because
people were sort of conspiring and yeah,
they were talking too much.
So one of the ways that God has
separated us,
I might be butchering this.
You're talking about the Tower of Babel?
Yeah.
They wanted to construct a coward or
each heaven and God was I guess like
fuck that.
It's like when ants get in your house or
whatever,
they're getting too advanced.
Do you think that's a reverse engine
mirrored idea?
Like do you think that someone who may
be has experienced like brief moments of
human potential and realized like w
we're missing out on what people are
capable of?
There's gotta be a way where we could
all come together.
Excuse me.
But when there's people from one country
like Japan and they're arguing with
someone from Germany and how much of
what the fuck each person is saying is
even getting through,
you know,
I mean you're having translators.
You were supposed to be going to war
with people.
You don't even understand what they're
saying.
Right.
Imagine that.
Yeah,
we've,
we get all speak to each other and we
all could speak one language.
What happened?
Well,
I mean,
isn't that like maybe what that tower of
Babel is all about?
Sort of like a reverse engineered,
like almost saying like the imagine the
power,
the God like power people could have if
they get all openly and honestly
communicate with each other freely and
ex experience this idea that we're not,
we're not,
you're not my enemy because you were
born over there.
Right.
This is nonsense.
This is some crazy old shit that we
should have abandoned.
I'm a go,
you are looking in the Bible.
Those stories.
One thing that I just did,
I'm so glad you brought this up just for
fun.
Uh,
one of my favorite in the New Testament,
my favorite Gospel is the book of John
in the very beginning of the book of
John is some of the trippiest shit
you'll ever read.
But I went back to that and so I did a
find and replace,
anyone can do this.
It's so cool.
Find and replace the word God with the
programmer.
And then you can start replacing words
with modern day,
a simulation theory ideas.
So you know,
um,
when it talks about Jesus,
it's like he was sent into the
simulation to bring an upgrade and those
that accepted the upgrade would be
children of the programmer.
You start doing that and suddenly you
look at this like amazing.
It gets really trippy,
right?
So when you talk about the Tower of
Babel and you look at it from the
perspective of this is a simulation
being run by some intelligent creator
force,
right?
So you see again and again,
well not again and again,
but right now I can think of two times
where the programmer looks at the
simulation.
It's like,
Oh shit,
they're about to wake up.
Like the same way the Ilan musk is
worried about ai becoming too powerful
in the Bible of the programmer gets
really fucking uncomfortable when the
simulation appears to be gaining too
much power and has to like shift the
programming a little bit because there
appears to be some kind of,
in the mythology of the Bible,
there seems to be a recurring
nervousness that the sim,
the programmer gets when it seems like
the simulation is about to reach some
certain level of power awareness.
This is in the book of Genesis.
They say,
you know,
they ate of the tree of knowledge of
good and evil,
gain self awareness and there was
another tree they weren't supposed to
eat from the tree of life.
And the uh,
God says it's weird because in the Quran
and in the Bible,
God ref,
it's referred to as the plural rather
than the singular.
So God doesn't,
the versus something like,
you know,
if they eat from the tree of life,
they will become like us,
right?
Not like,
like us.
So there's like a,
we can't keep these.
We have to keep these beings somewhat
curtailed because we don't know what
they're going to do if they gain too
much power.
That's in the mythology of the thing and
it kind of works from the simulation
theory perspective.
If we're a simulation that's on the
precipice of a kind of singularity,
which would be the simulation somehow
becoming self aware,
then for whatever reason,
whoever's running the show doesn't want
that to happen or hasn't wanted it to
happen throughout time,
you know?
Well it's also if you're talking about
like eating from the tree of life and
becoming like them,
uh,
I mean that is about a psychedelic as
you can get your literally talked about
eating something and becoming a god.
Yeah.
You're talking about eating from the
tree.
Like what is the tree of life?
Everybody's like,
oh,
whatever.
Yeah,
It's history.
It's,
you know what,
God,
there was trees back then.
Sure.
If you're a literal believer,
the Bible,
you have to think that there was not
just an experience where God showed up.
Right?
Not just this,
this,
this thing that happened where God came
down,
he spoke to you an elevator,
you know,
you're saying people shouldn't eat from
a tree.
Oh yeah.
Cause they could become a god.
Yeah.
I mean that's kind of where if you're
translating stuff from ancient Hebrew to
Greek to Latin into,
to all these different languages to
English,
you know,
that there's some weird shit being lost
along the way.
In one of them was probably calling it a
tree.
Right?
Because we didn't even know there's a
fucking amazing radio lab out.
It's out.
It's out right now.
It's about,
um,
about trees and the,
the intelligence of trees and that trees
communicate and that they share
resources that they allocate resources
toward the needier ones.
Yeah.
They have this interaction with fungus,
this symbiotic relationship with fungus.
It is fucking incredible man.
Where the fungus are eating these
microscopic bugs and getting their
nutrients from these microscopic bugs
and that's where the trees are getting
their nutrients from.
And some of them get him from,
from salmon.
There's trees that were like,
they got 70% of their nitrogen from
salmon because bears would eat under
these trees.
They would eat and they would leave like
fish heads under the trees and like the
bears would continue to return to the
same trees and these trees would eat the
fucking fish,
the,
the fungus inside their soil and the
Miko rise will relationship that they
have.
It's amazing man.
It's amazing dude there if their old
life form that we are sleeping on.
Yeah.
This plants like,
and this is not a dig against anybody
who's a vegetarian or anyone on the
other end of the spectrum that only eats
meat.
Take the ideologies out.
Like,
cause everybody knows that I meet or
everybody that listens to this podcast
and I,
I've had issues with people for that or
proselytizing vegans and I understand
that you're doing it for a good reason,
then you're doing it for the right
purposes.
And I'm,
I'm happy for everybody that that is
living their life that way.
If you're enjoying it and you're
healthy,
let's all just let that go.
Just look at this for a second.
Forget about what you're eating.
What plants are is some strange,
intelligent network of organisms.
And when I say intelligent,
I don't say it can fucking do math.
I'm not saying it can send emails and
create fucking moon rockets,
but they communicate with each other.
There's something going on.
They don't need to do all those other
things.
We defined intelligence far too
frequently by what we have created and
what what we can do with our fingers and
when our mouths and with our ability to
communicate with each other audibly and
in a manner where I'm talking and you're
hearing and we don't respect other forms
of communication because this,
we're so attached to our idea of what
communicating is.
We're ignoring some really basic shit
with how these plants and these fungi
communicate with each other.
They're there.
Fuck.
They're not just communicating with each
other.
They're sending signals.
If one of them is getting eaten,
they're sending signals through the air
and it's forcing the other plants to
change the,
they taste
to discourage predation.
They're communicating when they're hurt.
Wow.
Do the allocate resources to more needy
plants.
They find out who in the network is
needy and the allocate resources.
This,
this radio radiolab is fast and that's
cool man.
They share resources with these microbes
or with uh,
with these fungus you and also you,
cause you were saying,
well they can't send emails,
but if you look at,
I mean,
and you separated the human biome
somehow from the plant kingdom,
which you can't do,
we're completely connected to the plant
kingdom because we need oxygen to live.
So we are deeply,
deeply woven into that fabric of
intelligence that you're talking about
to the point that we actually kind of
grow out of that fabric of intelligence
because we have a symbiotic relationship
with plants,
uh,
just to exist on planet earth.
So you're talking about,
uh,
the what is called,
have you heard of the web of Indra?
No,
the web of injury or it's also called
the net of Indra or the web of Indra.
What does his from a,
this is hinduism.
So the idea is that a way to explain
this sort of inner connectedness,
connectedness of all things is this like
imagine like a web or a net where at
every single nexus point there is a
jewel,
the jewel dinette avenger.
That's what it's called.
So then,
uh,
now imagine that every creature on earth
are in this universe that has any kind
of sentence at all,
composes a tiny little jewel on this
net.
And so this net is every joule is
connected via like whatever connects us
to plants.
Everything is connected that's alive it,
which means that any slight movement in
any of these jewels creates a vibration
that rolls through infinity through the
entire net of Indra affecting all o
other sentient beings in some small way.
It's basically the idea is any third is
the jewel net avenger.
So anything that you do,
it gets sort of vibrated through the
rest of the thing.
Anything that happens in the micro
happens in the macro,
macro happens in the micro.
It's a beautiful idea,
man.
And,
and,
and it seems like this new discovery
that's come out about plants has a,
in some way really shined,
shone a light on the complexity of that
incredible net.
You know,
cause it's so complex because then it
gets down to probably the quantum level
too.
I mean,
if you think of the quantum reactions
happening inside the plants to create
these biochemical shifts,
it's startling when you imagine all the
weird chemical and atomic movement
that's happening inside of the thing
itself.
It's overwhelmingly beautiful and hard
to imagine that we get to be a piece of
it,
which is pretty cool.
But the plants are sending email,
you know,
because we are the plants,
the plants are us,
the plants are affecting rumor.
Mccann always talked about x.
So pheromones,
remember that Xcel pheromones,
you'd say that mirror that plants have
pheromones that they put out to like
what you're saying to discourage
predation.
Bring in bees.
I liked that.
I said per day session,
like I'm smart,
but it's a great word.
But the um,
uh,
so,
he would say that psychedelics
marijuana,
dmt,
these are Xo pheromones from the
vegetable world.
I gained deal on mckinna impression,
but these are x o pheromones coming into
our biome and shifting our consciousness
in a way to try to manipulate our
behavior a little bit.
And,
and also,
you know,
all this stuff coming out of the gut
biome to like,
not only is there this flourishing
vegetable kingdom that is like clearly
alive and has its own alien
intelligence,
but we've got fucking gut biomes filled
with these bacteria that could
theoretically be controlling our
cravings,
right?
So we're being manipulated by these
colonies of alien beings living in our
guts,
telling us,
get another fucking candy bar,
man.
Wouldn't it be good?
Isn't that cool?
So true.
Yeah.
It's so true.
There's this darkness inside.
You then want that sugar.
Yeah.
It's a little demon little demon that
feeds off sugar.
Well,
it's a modern,
it's a modern way of saying demonic
possession.
And the old days you'd be like,
you got a demon motherfucker.
Now it's like,
well,
your gut biome is craving carbohydrates
to survive.
Look,
if you've got the plague,
how's that any different than you being
attacked by Vampires,
right?
Something's trying to kill you.
We take comfort in the idea that it's
some microscopic thing that we can even
see because that makes you feel better.
That's looks a lot weirder than a
fucking vampire by the way.
A lot
weirder.
It's not a,
it's not a well dressed man with a cape
and things.
You're looking at some kind of strange
globular transforming bit of plasma
that's swimming around inside of you
actively trying to destroy you.
He came,
he came to see it.
We didn't even find them to like what,
when,
when did they invent microscopes?
If you had a gas?
18 hundreds I couldn't guess that.
And that's a sad thing man.
I couldn't guess that.
Let me,
I'm going to guess.
I think Brian Cowen was talking about
this in relationship to them discovering
bacteria with surgery.
Oh No,
it was Chris.
I think it was Chris Ryan.
I think Chris Ryan might've been the
first one.
I don't remember.
I'm now I'm giving people credit.
I'm not sure.
But um,
the idea was that they didn't know what,
what bacteria was for like a long time
and they didn't wash their hands.
And people die of horrible infections
when they were to do
surgery on people.
It's like,
Oh fuck the guy.
So this is,
I can't remember the guy's name.
You may be confined to Jamie.
It's the guy he was,
he realized so doctors would apparently,
uh,
they would like do autopsies on corpses
to try to understand how the human body
worked.
It used to be illegal.
I was like a big deal to cut open a
corpse says doctors are studying corpses
and apparently they didn't know you
should wash your hands after you handle
a Corp.
So you would like fuck around with a
corpse and then go deliver a baby.
Right.
And,
and the babies,
there was a very high infant mortality
rate,
so I can't remember his name,
but a doctor discovered,
oh wow.
Mind blowing idea.
You should wash your hands before you
deliver a baby.
And there it is.
Yeah.
He ended up in a fucking mental asylum
because they weren't listening to him.
And uh,
apparently what doctor said,
gentlemen,
do not need to wash their hands.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
A gentleman,
a gentleman does not wash his hands
because they're just innately clean.
Mm.
So yeah,
man,
people had no idea.
They thought that your com was filled
with tiny little men,
you know,
like little humans were in.
They're like tiny little,
yeah.
Yeah.
Why did they think that until,
until the microscope,
I imagine until finally someone fucking
came on.
Yeah.
Microscopy.
How long after the invention of the
microscope is someone shoot a load on
one?
Exactly.
However long it took to reach orgasm
after building it?
Well,
it's like we were talking about virtual
reality.
We're like,
how long before they made a porn?
I mean when the moment they came up with
Oculus,
we,
we knew.
Yeah,
I think it's a matter of time.
Yeah.
Matter of time.
And they did it and they did it.
Oh,
it is going to create some fucking
hilarious earthquakes and a lot of
different relationships and marriages
because people are going to have to
define whether or not fucking a Hologram
is a form of infidelity.
Like you're going to have to make a rule
for that and in your relationship,
is it okay to fuck a Hologram?
Not Alive,
not a person,
but looks like it's fucking you looking
you right in the eyes,
right in the fucking eyes.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Yeah.
It's pretty weird because your brain,
when a Hologram is looking at you in the
eyes in a loving way,
your brain doesn't reject it.
It's like,
oh wow.
I think this girl really likes me.
Oh wait,
it's a hologram.
But in one millisecond you get this
feeling of like strange connection,
which is a,
and again,
we're in the most rudimentary parts of
Vr,
only apparently only.
I just read this,
it might've been a dated article,
but only 100,000
people or so own an htc vive if that's
drastically off you guys.
I'm sorry,
but not a lot of people have vr goggles
right now.
So not a lot of people.
And there's a lot of us who are fucking
ear beating people at parties who had
clearly just don't want to hear about it
any more than you want to hear about
someone talking about it dream.
But there's a huge group of people right
now that are having some of the most
psychedelic mind bending experiences
through technology and they can't even
talk about it or describe it to people
because when you describe it,
it's like you're talking about a dream,
but you're like,
no,
this is happening to a lot of us right
now.
We're going into alternate dimensions
via technology and hanging out there,
enjoying it,
experiencing the freedom,
uh,
from the confines of being constantly in
an infinitely located in whatever
physical space your body happens to be
inhabiting to suddenly remove that
weights and how I can pop these things
on and instantly translocate to some art
universe that some geniuses created.
Fuck around.
Shoot Arrows,
wander through minecraft,
have sex with two girls who I always
apparently going to throw out of my
house if they didn't fuck me.
That's what the point is.
I have,
which by the way,
never do that.
But in this universe,
I guess that's what I go.
Yeah,
so the kind of rapey what?
It's not rapey.
It's just like,
please,
I don't have money for the rent.
Can I suck your Dick?
Oh,
you know,
it's her idea.
Oh yeah.
You're not saying you're not raping her.
It's not like,
look,
you gotta you gotta give up some posts
the other,
otherwise I'm kicking you in the street.
You could say it if you want into the
porn.
I mean,
you could say whatever you want.
Wait a minute.
You told me you have a microphone,
a microphone,
but you can talk to it if you want to be
a Weirdo,
but okay.
How long before you can talk to it?
Hello?
Four.
It talks back to you.
Well that's you're going to look,
you're looking at like a,
so we got to figure out a way to either,
I mean I imagine that probably exists in
some rudimentary way for some kind of
CGI style porn,
but to be able to like instantaneously
communicate with live video porn,
you're going to need some kind of ai
that I don't think we probably have just
yet or we are probably on the PR,
but yes,
that will ask come.
Oh,
that's definitely going to happen.
I've watched x Mckenna again on a plane
the other day.
I watched it for the second time.
That's cool.
It was just as good the second time.
That movie freaks me out,
man.
Why?
Because the girl's so beautiful and
she's so,
she's so attractive.
Like you,
you know,
that guy you could see as much as he
knew that she was a robot.
As much as he knew that he wasn't a
robot,
as much as he knew that she was
artificial,
he was in love with her and she was
amazing and it like she cared about
him and when she was talking to him for
real,
like when the lights went out and the
camera was down,
spoiler alert,
and she was like,
don't trust him.
I'm like,
this is like a real person,
a real person.
She's thinking like a person.
It's a person.
Yeah.
And he's like completely locked into
this idea that it's a person he's hipped
and tie.
It's a person.
I mean I don't,
this whole distinction between
artificial intelligence and intelligence
is the same as the distinction between
virtual reality and reality.
It's just like another human attempt to
be in control of something.
You want it,
you want to say,
Oh,
I'll tell you if this is fucking reality
or not.
Oh,
this is virtual reality.
This isn't reality reality.
But it's like,
oh really?
So reality is compartmentalized into
places where there's,
if something is created by a human,
oh no,
that's not real reality.
Even though humans are reality.
Reality is reality.
Intelligence is intelligence because the
intelligence is inhabiting something
that isn't the human vessel.
It goes back to what we were talking
about earlier,
what,
cause it's not in a fucking meat body
now it's artificial intelligence.
How is why intelligence is intelligence?
Yeah,
and again I think it goes back to what
we were talking about earlier that we
try to define intelligence by our own
measures,
like the ability to write something
down,
the ability to move.
How about that?
We,
we have that inexorably connected to
intelligence.
You have to be able to move to show me
your thinking and communicating.
Right?
Like despite what this woman was saying,
the scientist on this radiolab podcast
is that she goes,
I don't want to say that there.
She's like,
it's hard to say that if they're
intelligent,
it's hard to,
but what's going on is their net work
closely resembles a brain,
right?
The way it looks and also the way it's
operating.
They,
it's as neuron like responses.
Yeah.
There's,
there's data being passed back and
forth,
right.
That we're just not,
we,
not you,
not me.
For sure.
We don't,
we're not doing any research,
but these people,
we are somewhat,
I'm saying we as in humans,
they're just figuring this out really
recently.
I think everything has a conscience or a
consciousness.
I think every,
everything that you eat,
and I think that obviously plants for
the most part are like way less violent
than animals.
You know,
like when you are taking in plants,
it's just sent,
it seems to make sense that it would be
like a more peaceful existence.
Like the way you think about it.
Like you're,
you're just consuming plants.
Like glue it,
all the animals that only consume
plants.
Right.
They're all like really peaceful.
Yes.
But then the animals that consume
animals and plants,
they've got to get dirty.
Yes.
Those animals and the ones that only
meet those are the scary ones.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
Well it kind of makes sense.
I mean when a percent you need different
tools for taking down a deer than you do
for eating a piece of Broccoli.
Well,
it's just,
I think people are trying to like move
away from
the system that requires the violence
and like a part of that.
The idea of that is to eat plants
because like even if you're eating a
life form your,
you're,
you're less involved in violent
activity.
Like if you're eating meat,
you're involved in violent activity,
right?
Some way,
even fish,
you're involved in some sort of violent
activity.
Those fish have to be,
they don't just instantaneously die.
They've got to be yanked into another
dimension,
beat over the head with wooden clubs
thrown into ice checks,
chasse with,
they'll flop and gasp for air until they
finally go still.
I mean that's what happens when you eat
fish,
man.
You know,
it is one thing that is very,
they're all this indicates is how
there's so much compassion inside of
human beings because whether you eat
meat or whether you eat a vegetarian
diet,
if you're thinking about this,
it's really cool.
That's one of the cool things about us
is that we have this sense of like,
man,
yeah,
this does seem to be a violent thing
that I'm doing here.
I know this thing I'm eating has
suffered to some degree that I would
never want anyone I know to suffer or
myself as you know,
I th th so w there's compassion there,
man.
And we want to live in a world where we
don't hurt things.
And if you do want to live in a world
where you hurt things,
well then you're probably in a lot of
pain yourself,
right?
Yeah.
But so then,
but you get this is it man,
this is the fucking Bhagavad Gita
because the Bhagavad Gita starts with a
warrior are June looking out on this,
uh,
this fucking massive army and sang to
God the charioteer.
I see my friends here.
I see fathers and teachers and men that
I respect,
uh,
by killing them.
Don't I destroy my own soul?
Wouldn't it be better to go off into the
forest and live as it renunciate than
to,
to gain all the wealth in the world,
but to have the blood of my teachers on
my hands.
And this is the beginning of the bug of
I get in,
you would think because it's one of
Gandhi's favorite books that the
response would be,
you're right,
let's not kill,
let's not fight.
We're going to go in the woods.
But the response,
God says,
you speak words of wisdom,
but you do not understand.
That's the beginning of the Bhagavad
Gita.
That's where it starts is here's why you
fight.
Here's why you have to kill.
Sometimes.
Here's why.
There is action in the universe that
will result in pain and suffering.
And this,
uh,
is to me the best like answer to all of
this is a,
when Krishna reveals his universal form
is this cause called,
here comes this monstrous thing and
arginine is describing what he's,
and this is the oppenheimer quote,
Oh,
home become death destroyer of worlds.
And Arjun is saying,
I see in your teeth the limbs of all
humans being chewed and eaten,
your consuming everything,
your eating,
everything is basically what he's
saying.
And then he says,
can you please turn back into my
friends?
Cause it's so fucking intense to see
that.
And so that response is okay,
let's stop killing everything.
But look,
you're getting eaten by the universe.
No matter what you do,
you're being grounded dust by the force
of time.
There is no escape from this.
You are in the digestive tract of a
being that is gradually transforming you
into nothingness depending on what you
want to believe,
unless you think there's some eternal,
perpetual soul,
in which case the digestive system is
freeing you from the uh,
uh,
the terrible and limited in closure of
the human body.
Either way,
man,
we are being shifted and dramatic and
beautiful way.
And as that's happening to think that
you can somehow not realize what you
are,
which is you are one of the digestive
organs in the universe.
You are deaf.
No matter what you do,
man,
you are completely wiping beings out of
the universe.
It every single fucking second.
If your immune system's working,
those sweeties of burrowed into your
fucking skin and gotten into your mucous
membranes,
you're wiping them out,
your blood cells are heartlessly fucking
killing them.
And then maybe you had an ant on your
counter when you drove your car.
I'd say there's a 60% to 90% chance.
You probably ran over some tiny little
fucking bug that was walking across the
street.
You can't live in this universe without
killing things and um,
uh,
and you two are being killed.
So you are like,
uh,
in the [inaudible] you're like,
a little bit of stomach acid helping to
dissolve a steak.
You're a little bit of the digestive
process of the universe killing and uh,
out putting energy from that
destruction.
That's just what everything is really
not to like justify a meat diet.
If you could become a vegetarian,
do it,
be a vegetarian if it drawn,
if you're drawn to it,
it is a more peaceful thing.
We'll for sure factory farming is a
giant issue for anybody with a
conscience.
Then when you get into other forms of
acquiring meat,
then things get more complicated because
a,
if you're talking about hunting in
particular,
that's not easy for everybody to do.
And so it's almost impossible for
everybody to do.
Um,
so then you'd have to have ethical
farming and then you'd have to decide
what is ethical,
how they,
what does ethical mean?
Free range chicken,
free range cows,
free range chickens.
Um,
you know,
and you didn't have to decide that
there's certain cycle of life involved
here and then you're willing to take
part in it for your own health.
You're going to decide I'd like this,
my body functions better on this,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to allow this to happen or,
or help it.
Participant,
yeah,
he'll participate in it.
But um,
I think when you see a bear eat a
salmon,
that bear is not thinking for a fucking
second about the feelings of that
salmon.
It's just holding it down and tearing it
apart with no hesitation whatsoever.
When we reap,
let us from the ground.
Are we doing a more complicated version
of that?
Are we pretending that this thing is
this non feeling nonthinking thing
because it doesn't move and it can't
send emails.
But is it possible that all these things
that we call life,
all these things have a consciousness.
Everything does.
Squirrels,
people,
monkeys,
fucking Alfalfa.
Oh yeah.
All that shit.
It's,
yeah,
it's a,
this is what I was thinking as I've been
doing vr,
having so many philosophical thoughts
based on this incredible technology.
So this is what I started thinking is
that human,
all living things are like organic
virtual reality goggles,
right?
So like a squirrel is a,
is like a kind of virtual reality goggle
that the universe is gazing through in
the form of a squirrel's reality,
right?
So this consciousness,
this intelligence,
it's like an omnipresent force.
And every living thing is like a faucet
that its life is this intelligence
coming through and it's spreading itself
based on the energetic system of the
particular conduit that it's coming
through.
So a living squirrel is a portal that is
opened up to the intelligence of the
universe temporarily.
And when that intelligence flows through
the squirrel,
the way electricity runs through a
motherboard,
uh,
then it's odd.
It's,
it's animated,
right?
And so when the squirrel dies,
that it's not as though the intelligence
is gone.
It's just that that particular conduit
shots,
while there's a billion other conduits
in any biom filled with that
intelligence,
pouring through it,
um,
and behaving according to the way,
whatever the thing is that it's coming
through in the same way that if you have
a,
if you have a different ai programs with
different codes,
it's still processing the same energy.
It's just the energy is being
transformed based on whatever the
specific system is,
you know.
So when we meet,
we're in a weird way eating the virtual
reality goggles that some thing was that
infinity was using to experience reality
and that reality that it infinity was
experiencing through the vr goggles that
you're eating inside your bond was not a
great fucking,
uh,
experience,
you know,
so composed in those,
in that Goggle,
in that life form that you're eating.
This is what the Hari Krishna say is all
the fear,
all the terror,
all the,
the momentum of that being's life
somehow gets encoded into the,
uh,
atomic structure of the meat that you're
consuming.
And so you take a little bit of that
suffering into you and that degrades
your life in some slight way,
but totally me.
Makes Sense.
Totally makes sense that there's
something that gets through it.
I mean,
why would we assume that your diet
isn't,
I mean,
if you're eating biological particles,
why would we assume that they have no
influence on us?
Like we would think that there,
we just know.
I just,
I broke it down to protein.
Yeah.
Water.
And that's it.
There's no,
no chicken suffering in there at all.
No,
I ain't checking software.
No Way.
Not a,
not a trace of it,
but why not?
All a dullness?
Just a dull chicken suffering that you
get in your mouth.
Yeah,
just a kiss.
Delicious chicken.
But there's an undertone of existential
horror and my chicken waxy film on the
inside of your mouth.
Yeah,
just chicken sadness.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I can remember like when,
when I was a kid,
we didn't fucking,
you know,
like you kind of knew the animals were
like the people just were a lot like I'm
reading fucking listen to the audio book
rather of Moby Dick,
uh,
the Frank Mueller narration.
You ever read that book who's Frank?
Mueller?
Frank Mueller,
uh,
is the guy,
is the Vo actor who narrated the dark
tower series by Stephen King.
And he is the best.
And so I guess there's no way I'm
fucking reading moby Dick,
but listening to someone who understands
what he's reading helps you understand
it and uh,
cause he puts the inflection in the
right place,
the inflections are in the right place,
and he's clearly some kind of super
genius who just gets moby Dick.
And he understands every single fucking
passage that Melville endlessly writes
about the varied,
the deepest details of whales,
man Melville fucking love whales.
And the book is like a sort of portal
into,
before they knew that whales are
mammals,
right?
So,
you know,
we thought they were fucking fish
Leviathan,
right?
Isn't that funny that we make that
distinction?
Let's talk about that.
I like sat there fish,
fuck them.
Well,
they're mammals.
They're ass,
right?
Right,
right.
We can't do that.
We got,
we got weird teams.
Other teams weren't.
Okay.
So I'll answer to that.
If to use the virtual reality goggle
example,
let's imagine there's like 15 different
virtual reality goggles on the table
that represent a kind of spectrum of um,
technological advancement.
So here we've got a,
I don't know,
remember the old,
you used to have those like,
uh,
those stupid view finders you could flip
through and look at it.
Okay.
So on one side we have a view finder and
on the other side we've got some shit
that doesn't even exist yet.
Some neural interface,
you put it on a harmonic magnetic field,
interacts with your brain and you not
only go into a location,
but you experienced the memories,
emotions,
thoughts,
and dreams of the Avatar within the
game.
You literally become the figure that's
on the other side of the spectrum,
right?
So here we have this sort of like
spectrum of potential experience.
I think it would be safe to say that,
uh,
the experience of a Broccoli,
right?
Just based on the TAC in there versus
the experience of like a,
I don't know,
a fucking mit student genius who's like,
come healthy.
I'd say that you could say that there's
a varying levels of experience as to
what is being experienced.
Who's to say,
now that I say it,
I think I'm totally wrong.
I'm sorry for the rant.
Okay.
As a,
at the very end of it,
there was some part of me,
he's like,
just shut up,
man.
That's wrong.
That's not it.
So forgive me you guys.
I try with that one.
You just,
it,
it flopped.
In my own brain.
They don't all land.
They don't own the land.
If they did,
it wouldn't be fun.
It wouldn't be fine.
But I will admit when they don't land in
that,
definitely.
I think you're right,
man.
Why do we make the distinction?
It's like God damn weird distinction.
I mean,
it's an intelligence distinction.
Yeah.
We just decided to fish a stupid as
fuck.
But you know what?
They're not.
Here's the,
here's where they're not.
Here's one thing we eat all the time.
That is probably a smart as a monkey.
And that's an octopus.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah.
We talked to us all the time.
They are crazy smart.
Have you ever seen the new video that
they put out of an octopus going through
a key or a whole rather than just the
size of a quarter?
Yeah,
man.
I did see that.
It's crazy.
It's amazing what they can do to their
bodies.
This is insane.
And yeah,
Mckenna loved them.
Right?
He was like in love with Octopi.
Is that the plural Octopi?
That's a good question.
He was in love with it is he thought
that they were like the ability to have
multiple appendages and,
and,
and the crazy camouflage abilities they
have would combine to really,
um,
open up new levels of communication that
humans don't have.
Cause it seems like he was a,
he was a little frustrated by the
limitation of the human vocabulary and
the way we emote things to articulate
the universe.
So it'd be nice to have a bunch of
different limbs that had no bones that
you can turn any which way while
shifting colors that beats fucking
emoticons by shot man.
I mean they can change color.
They shoot ink into the air and he,
he
was one that I first heard speculate
that the ink,
when they shoot ink into the air,
that it might be like a racer fluid.
Like look how small that hole is and
look at this big ass octopus.
Get through this tiny hall.
I mean you would look at that hole and
you would have like,
there's no way,
but these things,
not only can they get out of a hole like
that,
but they can walk on land for long
periods of time,
climb back up into their fish tanks,
lift the lid,
get inside.
I mean they're aliens man.
That's,
I mean that might as well be on another
planet.
We're just used to it because it's on
earth.
The thing is a giant bulbous head,
long moveable arms.
He knows how to unscrew jars and he's
got like a kind of like cool,
relaxed look on his face.
Like he's,
he's definitely relaxed.
They're emotionless.
They're very strange.
It's a very strange being.
It's very different than a fish and uh,
but it lives with fish,
so fuck it.
I mean,
they're probably a smart as whales,
everything is alive.
That's the ultimate thing though.
That's the final place you got to get to
is that you are a part of a super
organism that is stretching through time
in the form of every generation of thing
that ever lived.
Right.
And it's currently like,
it's like this being that has an
infinite number of appendages that
represent all living forms of life on
earth.
And just like the same way that like you
investigate a thing.
All these impinj appendages have wrapped
around the planet and they're probing,
probing,
probing the planet.
So it's like every living thing is the
very end of an interdimensional
superintelligent appendage.
You know,
this is kind of like the,
uh,
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy where
he said that mice are just the ends of
the tentacles of his inner dimensional
creatures studying scientists that
laboratory mice,
he was a fucking genius.
But,
um,
in the same way,
when you look at like every single
living being on earth is actually
protruding from,
uh,
you know,
generation after generation of being
that stretches back to the beginning of
organic life on planet earth.
So it's like earth suddenly gets wife.
How,
who the fuck knows my theory aliens?
But who knows?
Maybe it just randomly happen.
Who knows?
But so suddenly springing from the earth
or these very rudimentary organisms that
over the course of millennia gradually
stretched out and changed to become
various types of devices,
to study the crevices,
crannies,
and,
and an air of this planet until
eventually it became monkeys and the
monkeys became people.
And now we're like a very advanced scope
that is peering into the atomic and
subatomic level of the fucking thing.
But when you look at a squirrel's life,
eagles life,
uh,
fucking,
salmon being eaten by a bear's life,
it's interesting to consider that what
you're seeing is an infinite number of
scopes through which something that
appears to be either investigating this
dimension or just enjoying being in it
is coming through.
You know,
that seems to be what's happening.
That is an idea that gets echoed in,
um,
uh,
and like some eastern philosophies and,
some,
uh,
it's,
it's an interesting take on it for sure.
What would,
what's definitely happening is there is
some consumption going on.
Everything's consuming something.
Yeah.
That's what this is the,
one of the things about this radio lab
podcast,
it was so fascinating where was talking
about these fun guide devouring
microscopic insects and um,
also like literally tapping into rocks
for minerals.
It's really,
really intense stuff.
And having this intense relationship
with these plants where they're feeding
off the root system and the root systems
are feeding them and they're feeding the
root systems.
They're exchanging sugar and uh,
and minerals.
Yeah.
It's really crazy,
dude.
I mean,
it's really,
really bizarre.
They were talking about miles and miles
of these microscopic fung fungi in the
soil in a tiny piece of soil and miles
and miles.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The mycelium,
right?
Yeah.
So like,
so when you,
okay,
so everything's eating itself,
but if you imagine that what you're
looking at is actually only one half of
the thing,
because we can't see into the
nothingness that happens after death,
then it could be that you're actually
looking at one,
just one part of a process,
right?
You're seeing just what you're,
you're seeing a limited part of an
infinite process that's happening where
death is just one piece of it.
But the thing that dies doesn't,
um,
isn't annihilated it.
Okay.
No,
go ahead.
It's not,
it doesn't go.
So the idea is it's like,
okay,
what you are is a thing growing out of
time.
Right?
You're growing from that,
which is not into that which is,
or that which is not known to that.
Which is is nice because where are you?
Where were you before you died?
Who knows?
I know you,
you're born before you were born.
Oh,
right.
Same thing.
According to some religions,
but uh,
so when you look at that as part of a
continuum,
right?
Instead of just like you are born and
then you die and then nothingness,
if you look at it as part of energetic
continuum of which we can only witness
this particular part of the continuum,
we don't have the technology yet to peer
into the other part of the continuum.
So if you look at it as an actual cycle,
then the brutality of the universe
becomes a little less significant
because you realize like,
oh no,
it's just like things diving out of the
nothingness into somethingness are
returning to the nothingness.
Then the same way a dolphin jumps up and
goes back down into the sea.
That's what we're doing.
Only when we dive into time,
we take on a form.
When we dive out of time,
we become the formless and then we come
back out of time again.
That's reincarnation.
It's reincarnation is,
I'm sorry if I've said on this podcast
before,
but reincarnation is like a fucking
dolphin trick only in this case,
the trick that you're doing is called
your incarnation and the particular way
that you live,
whether it's as it is for most people,
a kind of failure cause how the fuck are
you going to figure out what to do when
you dive into time for such a temporary
fleeting lifetime,
like to suddenly to be able to do back
flips and shit.
It's maybe you're not gonna be able to
do that right away,
but you dive out of time or out of
nothingness,
come into somethingness incarnate,
incarnate,
incarnate.
Here we are as a being have a life and
then you go back into the nothingness
again.
And so the people that we are most
amazed by in history or just people who
did really awesome tricks where they're
temporary human current incarnation is
they came jumping out of the
nothingness.
That's what we're in right now,
man.
Just a temporary transitory state of
harmonized Adams that have become aware
of themselves,
that are about to go through of
incredible energetic shift where you
become nothing and then maybe become
something again for infinity.
We have a real hard time having the
perspective of your body turning into
bacteria or you couldn't back to,
you're consuming your body when you die
of that not being a bad thing,
that it's a part of life and that you
will be conscious inside that bacteria
and then maybe your consciousness leaves
this and travels with you with your
cells and your DNA as you're being
consumed.
Yeah.
And then it becomes a part of some
gigantic matrix and that's what maybe
that's what you're tapping into when
you're doing things like dmt.
Yeah.
When you hit that well of consciousness,
whatever the fuck that is that you hit
when you,
you run into that sea of reality.
Yeah.
When I say reality like this,
but just intense God,
like no bullshit.
Like there's,
it knows everything.
There's no bullshit.
It's like you and you,
you,
you have to abandon all your worldly
thoughts.
Yeah.
Abandon all your ideas of life and death
and ego and just give in and be one with
the whole thing.
And maybe that's what we do all the time
when we're sleeping,
man.
I mean it's entirely possible that what
we don't remember is existing in that
realm and that that realm is something
that were just shut off from because for
us to get done what we have to get done
with this monkey body,
you can't be fucking contemplating that
all the time cause you're not going to
get shit done.
You're getting,
you get,
you're going to be your,
you're going to be philosophical,
you're going to be too confused.
You're going to be so blown away by the
images of that other world.
You can't handle it.
So you just,
the reality of life just completely
takes over.
Dude,
you didn't,
I mean I don't,
I don't think you meant to do it,
but you are take,
you waited when you said that the
essence of so many different religious
systems,
which is that here is this Omni present,
infinite ever replenishing creative
matrix of intelligence that is so much
bigger than I am.
It's incomprehensible and an end,
like you said,
you have to let go of all your worldly
ideas,
your thoughts,
your ego.
You have to let your ego die because
what the fuck are you going to do in the
face of that thing?
Are you going to hold on to the stuff
you're proud of?
Are you going to hold onto the,
the victories that you've achieved in
your mind,
newt flickering human incarnation?
When you're in the presence of the
source of victory in the universe,
what are you going to do there?
What's the correct reaction to have if a
thing like that?
We're real.
And so depending on what religious
system you subscribe to those,
all of those are answers to that
question.
You know,
and you hear the answer coming up,
uh,
in a similar way usually,
which is you serve it.
You try to become a servant to it
because,
because what else are you going to
fucking do?
Are you gonna you gonna are you gonna
teach it?
Are you going to show it how to do
something?
Are you going,
what are you going to show?
Hey guys,
relax.
I'm here.
Uh,
I know you've been waiting for a long
time.
Infinity.
Finally,
I'm amongst you with my wisdom,
my 47 years on planet earth as a tire
salesman who finally does dmt for the
first time.
Everybody sit down.
Oh,
got it.
You come back.
Yeah.
Let's start with roses.
I liked the color of them,
but maybe we make it a brighter red.
What do you think?
How about make it so dear?
Don't want to eat them.
My mom,
she has a fucking garden.
She's always mad.
The deer is eating them roses.
Yeah.
This is,
this is the,
um,
so this is,
yeah,
this is why I really love this.
Bhakti Yoga,
which is a cause it like takes that
idea.
There is a super intelligent creative
force in the universe.
And the word for it is Bhagavan and it
basically means maximum everything.
So ultimate beauty,
ultimate intelligence,
ultimate attractiveness.
Ultimate,
ultimate love.
It's the ultimate of ultimate's.
Right?
So this thing has,
um,
inadvertently,
I,
it depends on what version of it.
Probably not inadvertently,
but this thing has a kr,
this,
it's so potent that the way it's
interacting with time is that it's
breaking into an infinite number of
pieces that have all become semi or
super aware.
So it's consciousness is dispersed
itself through its creation and every
single minute element,
like some fractal,
every single little piece of it is a
possessor of this infinite
consciousness.
And so that infinite consciousness is
the source of love.
And um,
it's basically,
uh,
let's you fall in love with it if you
want to and it loves you too,
which is the,
what's really trippy to imagine.
This is a thought experiment,
man.
Imagine that thing you just described,
that infinite fucking thing,
the no bullshit thing that demands that
you drop your history like a fucking old
nasty bag of shit.
Imagine if that thing also was aware of
you completely and also loved you.
Imagine that shit man.
That's the craziest idea ever.
That's a crazy fucking idea.
That's better than you know,
like when you like kind of like a girl
and you start thinking like maybe you
don't do this because you're a fucking
muscular super billionaires.
It's the host the UFC.
But somebody like me,
when I,
if a girl starts liking you,
you start thinking like,
holy shit does this girl,
I think this girl likes me.
I think this beautiful,
incredibly beautiful girl likes me.
Could this be,
that's the beginning of all love songs,
right?
That's the beginning of,
of like all human happiness is holy
shit.
The girl I like likes me back.
I think she likes me.
Holy Shit.
I think she's falling in love with me.
This incredibly beautiful girl.
So Bhakti Yoga is that exact concept
transferred to the universe.
So now you're like,
wait a minute.
This entire,
the source of all things in the universe
has a personality and it seems to love
me.
Not No fucking tame way.
Not In like the way that you might hear,
like Jesus loves you and then you
imagine it being like,
that means you could go over to his
house and sit down and have like a
boring cup of tea and leave,
you know,
like that,
that,
that kind of love.
No,
this is a fucking wild,
savage,
unpredictable.
Love the way your best friend loves you
or the way that like a comedian loves
you,
which is like,
you don't know what the fuck's going to
happen.
It's not the way the comedian loves you.
Yeah.
You know,
like comedians are going to do weird
shit.
If you're friends with Comedians,
you're going to get a lot of like weird
fucking pictures sent to you.
You know,
on a regular basis.
You're going to get people calling you
and playing tricks on you from time to
time for no other reason than just to do
it.
Right.
But they love you.
They fucking love you.
That's what's behind it.
So in the same way,
this is the concept,
it's not a team kind of love.
It'll kill you,
like it'll eat you,
but it's still loves you.
And it'll eat you because it knows that
you're just a fucking pair of virtual
reality goggles.
You're just a temporary flickering thing
that's going to keep going on forever.
This ego in the survival mechanism is
what makes us think that it's more
important to root for our team.
Like we have teams,
right?
So first of all were teen prime mate.
Don't eat any primates.
Yep.
Once you get past team primary were teen
mammal.
So if you have a choice between killing
a gigantic fish or killing a gigantic
mammal that you thought was a fish,
you got to kill the fish so you can kill
fucking blue Marlin's all day long.
Bring those bitches in,
chop up and the stakes.
But don't make oil for lamps.
I love Moby Dick.
That's fucked up.
Fucking oil out of the suite,
the bad guy.
You're the bad guy.
And I agree.
You know,
for whatever reason,
especially with uh,
with whales,
I have a thing for whales,
have a thing for whales and orcas and
dolphins.
I'm fascinated by them,
like legitimately perplexed.
I think that it's entirely possible,
but both by,
both with both dolphins and orchids,
that they're just as smart as us.
They just don't express it the same way.
They have a,
they have a different,
different kinds of existence.
They don't need,
they don't want to dominate other than
controlling food.
They just want to have food.
And once they have food,
I,
you know,
I don't think,
I just think when you,
when you listen to a scientist talk
about their dialects and the fact that
the pod stays together for life and that
they,
uh,
they form these tight bonds and they
communicate over great distances with
sound frequencies and these complex
languages that they recognize are
different in different areas.
So they recognize they're similar
sounds,
but there's a dialect to it.
They still don't know what the fuck
they're saying.
And part of the reason why we don't want
know what they're saying,
it's just like how we were talking about
emojis being like a form of hieroglyphs.
I don't think we can understand the
context of communication.
When you live in the fucking ocean and
you kill fish with your face all day.
I think what we would think of is,
where is your house?
Do you guys have cable?
How do you guys find out about,
you know,
when the movies are playing,
know that this idea of communication to
us,
like what,
what they're trying to do is locate each
other,
let each other know their moods,
let each other know their whole right.
Let each other know.
But we think that,
that,
that's rudimentary in comparison to our
complex system of sounds and very
repeatable sounds that we can all
express back and forth to each other.
But we just like emojis,
like what they're doing,
dressing themselves in,
in a,
in a way that they all understand.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
And don't forget they have an awareness
of,
of part of the larger part of the earth.
We don't know what the fuck is down
there.
Right.
That's one of the,
that's one of the,
uh,
moby Dick right after the spoiler.
They kill the fucking whale moby Dick
back right after the,
in the description,
the description of the way they kill
this fucking thing.
The way they did it back then,
which is you know,
you getting a ship,
you roll up to the thing,
there's a harpoon year,
he's got a fucking Harpoon,
he's got to sing it at the thing and
then you've got a tire it out.
Real it.
And this is a fucking whale,
right?
This is a Leviathan,
You're just a little fucking human in a
fucking boat and you're like nailing
this thing with a harpoon.
Finally,
when it gets tired enough,
you have to find its heart.
Oh my jam,
the Harpoon into its heart.
And then basically like fuck the whole
with a Harpoon,
just jab it in and out of that fucking
hole until finally,
this is description makes you want to
cry.
It's so awful.
Finally like the whale out of its blow
hole at like shrieks like uh,
like car breaks or something.
Like it's screaming in pain and then it
just blows chunks of guts and lung and
heart out of its own glow.
And then it fucking dies.
Then you got to get it back to the ship.
You tie it to this side of the ship.
Sharks start feasting on the fucking
thing.
So you have like sharks and your God
damn whale.
It's somebody's job to get lower down
with a Harpoon and kill the fucking
sharks.
And Melville Describes Melville,
describes killing sharks.
He's like,
you will stat,
you watched the hard paneer stab the
shark.
The shark will start eating its own inch
rails cause it'll,
it'll just start eating itself.
And then just like tying itself up into
a,
not as it eats itself in a frenzy.
That's our Melville describes it.
Those poor fucking whales man.
But after the,
uh,
they kill a whale.
Ahab,
Captain Ahab,
poor sad,
Captain Ahab.
He comes out and he like does a funeral
for the whales head.
And he like says like,
what have you seen down there?
What have you seen the graves of
millions of sailors,
the wrecked ships that no one will ever
know or there,
that's what a whale see.
So they just have this awareness that we
don't like.
We'll never know what the fuck's down
there.
We hardly can.
Yeah.
We don't know what like,
I mean the earth is three quarters
water,
right?
Yeah.
So the,
what's the low?
Yeah.
What's below the water is a two thirds
or three guide on.
Now there's a three,
five and measured lately.
Whatever it is,
it's a lot,
right?
It's a giant chunk of the earth.
Yes.
All water.
That's why it blew the,
the underneath stuff we so rarely see.
I mean,
do we see it?
Is that we do we see at 1% of what we
see above ground?
The um,
Oh God,
I hate to always talk about it,
but a brief history,
nearly everything he describes it as
like,
and this could be wrong,
I don't know,
but what we know about the ocean,
imagine if someone took like six
tractors and drop them in the middle of
Middle America and they drove around for
a few nights with their lights on at
night.
Some,
some description like that.
Can't remember.
But it's like it's,
it's that limited because getting a
fucking thing underneath all that
pressure,
it's not going to break down.
Getting out there in the first place,
you know,
to get the thing down that can survive
that pressure.
Forget it.
Pasta takes a
special kind of crazy person that's
willing to get in a submarine.
Oh,
oh Jesus fucking Christ.
I think I'd rather go to space.
I think I'd rather go to space and be
stuck at the bottom of the fucking Osha
and then see a drop of water on the side
of the wall going,
what is that?
What is that?
What's going on?
Shit,
man.
What is that noise?
Did you hear that noise here?
Yeah.
Twinkie.
And you know,
it's just like a fucking beer.
Can I,
one of those?
You ever see a stripper crush a beer can
with their tin.
They hold a beer can up and they have
one of them whopper tits,
like those double f jammies and they
hold it by the base because those tits
are always like,
you know,
they're,
they're sort of like a,
like a ball on the end of a,
an old rope.
Right.
You know,
cause you have the big round ridiculous
sized implants and they hold the beer.
Can they just molly whopped up beer can
and crush it.
That's how I would feel if I heard a
clink clink clink that I knew that
eventually the thousands of pounds of
pressure was just going to smush that,
that tank.
I just,
that's a fucked up way to diamond here.
They go,
look,
look behind you.
Boom.
Oh Wow.
I didn't know this.
They do this boom boom,
which is crushing them with her tits.
That has to hurt.
We'll get Steve Harvey.
Hmm.
There you go.
Wow.
Now you know it's a thing.
Now I know.
So that's what I think of when I think
about submarines.
You think when she did that?
Yeah.
Man.
You think she did that the first time
she did that?
She was angry?
No,
she was on meth the first time for sure.
Is that what she said?
No,
that's what I would guess.
I think a lot of girls have done that.
That's a trick.
That's like the when you not,
but she keeps sucking.
That's that mixed boobs.
Crushing beards.
First girl to crush a beer can with her
boob was on match.
No,
she's probably a real girl.
First of all,
like she had real boobs.
I mean,
not just a real girl.
Yeah.
You're all real girls by the way,
and everybody's a real girl.
Yeah.
If you want to be a real girl,
you're a real girl.
Right?
Right.
But like how many guys are broken beer
cans with their dick?
How about zero?
Tits are way more powerful and Dick in
that regard,
and what guys ever like held a beer can
down and smashed it with his hog oak has
a greater man than anybody in this room.
Plus,
especially if he does it right side up
and he gets the lip of the,
the beer can the thin park slams against
his dick with the kind of force that's
required to bend a beer can.
You're going to
crush your deck,
you're going to hurt your Dick.
I gotta disagree with you,
man.
I think he becomes,
I think he becomes the hero if he's
like,
if he's tied up and he's got to use his
dick and the beer can as a form of
escape device,
like at that point it becomes more
heroic than just,
but you're right.
I mean,
no matter what,
if you smash a beer can with your cock,
then you join some invisible,
more elite than the Illuminati.
I bet it's smaller than the seven
families that control everything.
Do you think there's like a 14 inch club
was all dudes were 14 to talks just
hanging out.
There's gotta be more than one dude on
the planet that has more than a foot
long duck.
Right?
If there's girls that have kids like
that,
and obviously those are fake,
but people are weird,
right?
People are built strange.
There's guys that are seven feet tall.
There's people that are five foot one.
There's a whole bunch of people in
between and someone out there as a 14
inch Dick for sure.
Like how many of them?
Well I mean based on my own experience.
Three and they're all assholes.
But well there was that one guy who kept
getting caught at the TSA because he has
his,
his hog is gigantic.
So he,
I keep saying hog cause it's fun.
Yeah.
Why is you calling her a log?
What are you 12?
Yes.
Um,
he's got a like a fucking sock.
Like a rolled up sock.
Yeah.
That's what is his hog is we know the
story or we've probably talked about in
the park,
you know the story of John Malcovich,
right.
Being John Malkovich comp,
John Malcovich the actor.
Right,
right.
So that supposedly they had to get him a
body double and a nude scene in a movie
because his cock is so gigantic that
they thought nobody would believe that
was a human's Dick.
So they had to get a body devil with a
smaller cock to,
uh,
have him stand in.
Because his penis is so large that it
would disrupt the flow of the narrative
to the guy who's telling you this suck
your Dick.
He'd said it while he was sucking my
Dick and the WHO I believe our biggest
dangers,
his dick,
a survey they're looking at.
I think it is.
It feels lucky enough phonies.
They look up as if that's confirmed
somewhere.
I think it's confirmed.
I have a feeling that's what's called a
rumor.
I have a feeling John Malcovich has a
great publicist.
Yeah.
He's like this story.
That's a good move.
Well,
if I,
I could imagine he would have a giant
hug.
James Woods supposedly has a giant hug.
That's the word he's telling him about
it.
He's talked about it pretty openly.
Trump trump has a giant one did.
He says,
fine.
He says it's fine in comparison to his
hands,
but it's the fact that the guy's running
for president and he was joking around
about his dick not being tiny.
That is hilarious.
I don't,
you know,
I don't know if he's going to make the
best leader of the free world,
but,
uh,
I welcome someone who's willing to make
a dick joke while they're running for
president.
I welcome that.
Well,
it's going,
it's like,
it's gonna be,
uh,
it's going to be a,
it's going to be really,
um,
interesting.
You know,
I was thinking,
we were talking about the fucking
elections anyway,
man.
And,
uh,
you know,
what's causing all the trouble right
now?
What?
It's this,
it's,
this is all technological disruption.
Like we're looking at,
this is all a result of technology.
I was thinking like,
what's the,
um,
what's the F if,
okay.
If you could like locate the problem,
right?
It's the,
I don't mean to jump from a damn
fantastic conversation about an enormous
cox to some kind of political shit ever
worry about where our conversations go
lover.
So thank you.
So,
so,
uh,
the,
what you're looking at here,
man,
is,
uh,
what Ray Kerr,
this is a quote from Ray Kurzweil,
which is things aren't getting worse.
Our information's getting better,
right?
And so with Hillary Clinton,
who is a career politician,
right?
And we've all known since we were young.
Most people,
I think when they think about
politicians,
they don't think those are some honest
people.
Those politicians,
they usually,
you're telling the truth.
I think most of his think politicians,
they lie,
they warp things,
they fabricate things.
They use a form of deception to gain
control of various power structures.
That's what the animal does.
So that's not new information when you
find out that Hillary Clinton and the
DNC,
and I don't know if they completely
connected those two,
but when you find out that they,
they,
they were not,
uh,
they didn't do what they're supposed to
do.
They helped Hillary Clinton become the
Democratic nominee and they actively
tried to fuck up Bernie Sanders.
Right.
That's creepy.
Yeah.
What?
It's not a new thing.
I know,
but it is creepy.
It's creepy.
And it's even more creepy that the woman
who was in charge resigns and then
immediately gets hired a great shot and
got a great job.
Hillary Clinton's like,
fuck it.
I'm going to hire you and it won't do
anything.
She hires her.
She's so fucking unafraid of what's
going to happen that she hires the woman
who did such shitty thing.
She had to resign booed off stage,
hires her into her fucking party cause
she's like,
fuck you,
I'm getting elected.
You're not stopping it.
Right.
But this is again tech.
It's gangster too though.
It's also a move in on her part where,
I mean she's looking at like what trump
is calling her crooked hillary.
Yeah.
It's a gangster move to hire a woman
like that.
Like right in front of you.
Yeah.
Wasserman Schultz top post mission
accomplished the DNC.
But this is,
this is not a new,
this is not a new thing man.
This is what exactly,
well let's go over this.
Cause what exactly did they do that's so
awful about Bernie?
What did they do?
So
they apparently came up with a way to
disseminate information to the press,
highlighting certain aspects of Bernie
Sanders that would be unappealing to the
voter.
And they did
this.
And this has all been confirmed.
Can you,
can you,
uh,
Google that?
Find out what they actually said.
Let's find out what the actually
summarize the Wiki leave.
We think they're being a bunch of whiny
bitches,
but for sure they wanted him look,
she's got way deeper arms in politics.
She's way more connected than he is for
sure.
There's,
and this is what we're seeing too,
there's like a big part of being a
political candidate is how many favors
do you have?
How many people you are you connected
to,
how,
how deep does your influence go?
And obviously her influence didn't just
sit within her are her own little group
of people that were working for it had
gotten to the DNC itself.
So she's,
she's deeply embedded in this whole
system,
whether it's because of friendships or
ideologies or people just wanted her,
she's the chosen one.
Whatever reason,
whatever deals were made or whoever,
who knows who knows what it is.
But when you find out that an
organization that's supposed to be the
head,
it's supposed to be,
if we,
if everything was on the up and up,
it's supposed to be objective and
looking for what the people want or as
the best party.
But no,
they're actually actively steering,
which is massively corrupt and kind of
scary because if these people are
deciding to steer an entire party yeah.
Which is 50% of a political process
because there's no,
look,
you've,
we've got libertarian party for the
first time,
people are taking Gary Johnson.
Seriously,
it's going to do that.
Um,
uh,
a town hall debate on Wednesday or town
hall,
one of those town hall things on
Wednesday on CNN,
but for the most part it's Democrats or
Republicans in most people's eyes.
So what they're essentially doing is
rigging half of that process.
Yup.
That's carrie that we just,
we don't think anything's wrong with
that,
but we put Martha Stewart in jail for
not telling exactly the truth about
where she bought and sold stocks or
whatever the fuck
we eat about.
We do think something's wrong about it,
but we can't do anything about it.
We do think something's wrong,
but right now,
okay,
so if like that institution is corrupt
and if the Republican institution is in
some ways corrupt,
I think it might be safe to say,
and I don't think too many people would
be outraged at the idea that there is a
institutionalized corruption in the
entire American political system and
it's very similar to the problem that
happens in bike racing.
If one mother fucker regs their bike or
gets on fucking doping stuff that can't
be detected.
If you want to have a fair advantage,
you've got a regular bike and start
doping to,
or the person who rides their bike will
always win.
So if politics is a competition,
which it clearly is,
and if members of the competition are
using nefarious means to achieve their
goals,
which they clearly are,
then that would imply that if you wanted
to survive in that system,
you would also have to use nefarious
means dom,
dom,
and this is not new.
This is old,
old,
old shit.
What's new is technology.
What's new is now people like Julian
assange are shining a light on the
corruption and his whole ideas.
If I reveal this information,
it will force reform via the outrage of
the people who are supposed to be
represented by a person who's breaking
the law.
That's his idea.
We need reform.
And right now we're at the point where
it's very similar to when you're in a
family and this is one of the worst
things can fucking happen,
man.
In a family.
If there is somebody who's molesting
somebody,
it happens all the time where,
uh,
a father or a brother,
we'll start fucking molesting somebody,
right?
But in people in the family know it,
but they don't do anything about it.
Because to talk about what GRANDPA does
every couple of years means that
complete disintegration of the fucking
family and apocalypse for the family and
the same way is more of these
revelations become clear,
which we always knew.
But you could always float into a happy
place and be like,
Nah,
I'm just being a conspiracy dude.
I'm sure the stuff they're doing up on
Capitol Hill is all fair and square.
I,
you know,
you can just believe it guiding.
You just pretend to believe.
Now it's like,
well now you're wrong.
Look,
hey,
here's the fucking proof and here's
going to be more proof and there's going
to be more proof and there's going to be
more proof until finally the American
people are going to have to either just
be like,
oh,
I'm just going to believe that fours
three and three is four because I have a
nice comfortable life and I don't want
to fucking deal with this shit,
man.
I'm just going to trust the banks
because the banks light,
they like money and at my job and as
long as I keep my job,
I'll keep my benefits.
Yeah,
and by the way,
ps,
man,
when you consider that,
it's like there's something pragmatic
about that.
As sad as it is.
There's as,
as,
as depressing it is,
is it is,
but they're,
the real awful problem is that this
country,
I think is that they get metaphysical
machine that was built by some very
intelligent people who understood the
energy flow that comes through a society
and the elections were supposed to be an
outlet valve for the pressure that
builds up when people feel that they're
being repressed.
Right.
And if you start fucking with that
output valve by putting up fake
politicians that don't truly represent
the people and hope that the people will
believe that they have elected these
people,
if you put two shitty choices in front
of us and we're supposed to look at that
and be like,
okay,
everything's fine,
then you're,
you're missing the point,
which is that there is an energetic
system that needs to get released.
You know,
at some point the energy's got to out.
If it doesn't go out,
you get revolution.
That's the way the energy goes out the
wrong way.
The idea is let's fucking the American
revolution,
brutal,
bloody,
awful fucked.
These geniuses,
many of them freemasons got together and
they were like,
you know what?
Is there a way that we can program
history so that a society doesn't
destroy itself intermittently with a
fucking revolution?
Because if we could do that,
we'll build one of the most powerful
never ending societies on earth because
we figured out a way to outflow the
pressure that builds up.
So when you start fucking with a goddamn
political system and pretend that
everything's gonna be okay,
you are missing,
I think the the point which is that
people who are very smart,
maybe a lot smarter than then the
politicians we have today recognize
something,
built a thing and said,
let's just trust the fucking people.
Let's trust the people release the steam
and while ah,
everything runs according to plan.
Now the gears are a little fucking
gummed up man.
A little,
yeah,
a little how gummed up?
How gummed up the gears.
Really crazy gummed up.
I think this is the first time we're
realizing how much money people make by
running for president.
How much,
you know,
money it costs to run for president.
But how much money top political figures
make and donations and in speeches.
Yeah.
Have you,
have you paid attention to how much they
make and speeches like Rudy Giuliani and
Hillary Clinton and Bill Clinton,
you may,
may bribes.
Well,
this is what it is.
These corporations can fund various,
uh,
universities.
They can donate money to all sorts of
different programs where they would have
someone speak and they can decide who
gets to speak and who doesn't get to
speak.
And they also have like the Clinton
Foundation,
people donate money into that.
They don't donate fuck loads of money.
Now it's her,
all these things,
but hold on a second says all these
things,
what they are essentially,
or you're,
you're paying someone to speak for an
hour and you're gonna give him $750,000.
And you want me to pretend that that's
normal.
That's crazy.
And what does this person do?
They are a public servant.
Okay.
So there are public servant,
and while they're publicly serving,
they're also making $750,000
to talk.
Huh?
That seems a little crazy,
doesn't it?
Like why do they make so much money to
do that and who was paying them and
what,
what do you have to benefit by having
them come and read some nonsense,
bullshit,
boring speech.
A friend mine went to see Rudy Giuliani
after post nine one one when he was on
his victory tour,
he was on like a lap of the country
doing these,
these speeches because everybody loved
him because he saved the world during,
you know,
September 11th he was the guy who stood
strong,
everybody like wow,
rudy Giuliani,
he's a good man.
So he rode that and he started doing
these speeches and would come to
colleges and a friend of mine went to
see him and said it was dog shit that he
just,
it was a boring ass like reading with no
passion.
It a chick chain.
Go in there and say some nonsense about
freedom and the American way and
terrorism or whatever the fuck and first
responders and just there wasn't
anything real.
It was just,
it was a performance.
It was like he was doing a one man show
all across the country for exorbitant
sums of money.
God,
that'd be fucking great if he was
actually doing a one man show,
hundred and $53 million in bill and
Hillary Clinton speaking fees
documented.
This is just,
Jamie just pulled this up.
That dad is stunning.
That's s dunning amount of money and
what we're 15 years is from 2001 to
about now it's it still it's more than,
yeah,
that's mean.
Well,
it's perfect then because that's $10
million a year.
This is more recent of what she,
she had 20 225,000
that's our standard fee.
Oh my God.
She prefers a private jet and prefers a
gulfstream four 50 or larger.
The memo outlines had Clinton requires
travel by private jet.
Yeah.
You know,
it'd be fucking cold out.
Is this like what if you are like a mad
billionaire?
Could you just get Hillary Clinton to
come to your house and like just speak
to you for an hour and your living room?
This is fascinating.
Hold up,
scroll back down there.
She made $21 million doing what?
She made 21 point $6 million in speeches
and just under two years.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
That's so much money.
She's like a kind of like crazy animal
that you can like lure with money.
Like you can actually,
if you have enough money you can learn
to Hillary Clinton into your house.
Like you just have to lay it out.
She'll show up.
Like if I put carrots in my backyard,
I'll probably get a rabbit or two.
If you have enough money you can get
politicians to come and start feeding it
your mansion.
Where do you,
when does it become,
when does it become bribe?
Okay,
so should she like say,
well you can never be,
it's weird,
right?
You couldn't be someone who is in public
office and go and also have like a a
book reading tour where you read from
your novel about crime or something like
that.
You'd have to be like a no fiction
person who's we?
When you're talking,
you're talking about what you do for
work.
That's part of what you're talking
about.
Like,
nobody's going to re ask Hillary Clinton
to come and speak about the history of
jazz in the United States.
Right.
She's not going to give speeches on
that.
It's going to give speeches on politics.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
okay,
so why is that okay.
Why can you like have two jobs?
That means you're having a second job.
Like you're doing your job.
Like you're,
you're saying the things that you say
during your job,
but somebody else is paying you to,
why is it okay that,
why is it okay to do that?
Like that seems like that's like,
that seems like very problematic.
Right?
Why is it okay for your husband to go
talk?
Who has he talked to you that the head
of the,
whoever the prosecutor who was it eats
district.
His Bill Clinton went and had this
secret meeting with what's his,
who was it about what?
Well,
right.
Oh,
right,
right.
Lindsey,
what the Hell is her name?
Lost it.
Damn it.
The point is like,
you just are openly like hiring,
hiring the,
the,
the woman who somehow warped the process
of getting a Democratic nominee there.
Yeah.
What's her name?
Loretta.
Loretta Lynch.
Doesn't that sound like a country
singer?
Is that?
Uh,
yeah.
That's fine.
First I was like,
yeah,
Loretta Lynn,
right.
That's what it sounds like.
Loretta Lynch.
Yeah.
Now she met Bill Clinton meets with the
attorney general on an Arizona Tarmac
now.
Right.
By the way,
flew in on his private plane and said
that he,
it was impromptu who not fuck flat and
prompt to on a private.
Yeah.
Hey,
you know what?
who are we flying over right now?
Wait,
are we flying over Loretta Lynch?
Oh,
come on,
stop down and we'll get a piece of apple
pie.
She's a good wall.
And we're going to sit on the porch and
drink lemonade.
Talk about our grandchildren on the
porch,
on the tarmac.
Nothing I love more than a nice,
a nice picnic on the tarmac of an
airport.
This is the other thing that she lied
about being dead broke after leaving the
White House.
Not only dead broke,
but in debt.
She said that apparently the system,
so not true.
Yeah.
And now and now it's like t tea to make
matters worse.
It's like you have to,
there's this weird idea that it's like,
listen,
you might not like Hillary fucking
Clinton.
Can you go back to that real quick?
But they're like,
you better shut the fuck up about her
because do you want trump to be
president?
That is what's going on,
right?
Yeah.
So
it says here,
this is what,
this is where it's confusing.
It says,
when Hillary filed a financial
disclosure document after entering the
Senate in 2001 she reported assets of
less than 1.8
million in liabilities are more than 2
million.
Well,
where are they doing?
What were they doing with all the money?
What he's spending money on?
There's like,
who the fuck?
Okay,
who has like $2 million in assets and in
$2 million in debt?
Do you have $2 million in debt?
No.
Most people don't have $2 million in
debt.
That's,
that's a crazy amount of money.
Like,
did you guys have a budget?
You're dead broke.
Now you guys are crazy liquid.
He party and you guys do a blow and
buying Ferrari's.
Just staying on a Amazon later.
Who the fuck gets $2 million in the hole
like that.
That is like,
if you want to have someone that you
wanted to balance the budget,
wouldn't you pick the person that
doesn't get 2 million in the hole?
I mean,
no man,
it tried,
trump's been bankrupt a gang at times
too,
right?
As he been bankrupt.
Yup.
That's what they say.
He says he likes going bankrupt.
It's somehow part of some plan.
But now the question,
what about the shit about Saudi Arabia?
What is this?
You don't remember this?
I remember when it,
it's like Saturday night live was making
jokes about them stealing like,
uh,
like silverware
and fine China and stuff from the,
when they were like leaving like on
their last days there last,
oh,
that's what year was.
This was like two and from 2000,
like when they were literally leaving in
the bushes were coming in.
Oh my God.
Taking all sorts of extra artwork and
all kinds of things.
And I don't know if it's true,
but it's,
I don't think the meme has gone away.
I don't know,
man.
Ha.
That's hilarious.
Oh No,
no,
she's so gangster.
Pardon me.
Look,
look,
I,
I kind of appreciate it in a way.
She's like our Putin.
Great,
great.
Just what we need.
We appreciate some gangster,
she is,
there's a video going around of her
talking from 2000 about not having email
and then imagine if she had emails like
what the investigators would find.
Sure.
Of course if fine.
It's on Mike Pence,
his twitter page.
Didn't she take money from Saudi Arabia
or is that bullshit?
Allegedly?
I'm not really her accountant so I can't
just,
I don't know.
I just,
you know,
man,
I think it's a,
it's like a crazy time right now because
we're actually getting to witness that.
The,
the cool thing about all this shit is
nefarious as these assholes want to be
there.
There they can't keep up with
technology.
They are being exposed technologically
and that's going to continue to happen
and that's pretty fucking bad ass man.
They get,
no matter how powerful or gangster
Hillary Clinton is,
she has apparently zero security on our
computer systems are very little
security.
And maybe if she had great security,
she still couldn't stop the infiltration
of a hackers.
And this is going to keep happening and
happening and happening until either we
just accept that our politicians are
innately corrupt or we come up with some
fucking way to starve them out to make
it so that they are.
But how,
I mean we'll,
do you think Bernie was like the first
step in that?
Like Bernie's no perfect person,
right?
I'm not the most gigantic Bernie Sanders
supporter because of talk to economists
that tell me that what he was proposing
is not fiscally possible.
Yeah.
So I don't know if they're right or he's
right.
And it's all real tricky to me.
Like the idea of democratic socialism.
Like,
boy,
it sounds good.
It sounds good.
If people got more,
I'm,
I'm warming up to the idea of universal
basic income.
I kind of liked that idea because I
think if you think about how much
resources we spend on things like cops
and firemen and d damaged on and police
and fire,
um,
uh,
rather prisons and how much time maybe
we could avoid some of that.
Like maybe a big chunk of it.
I think universal basic income has like
some real,
there's got some,
it's something that we should explore as
a culture,
but we,
I think also requiring people to do
certain things like in the community
requiring some sort of community
service.
Like how nice would it be if a,
I mean,
it's nice to be able to pay someone to
take out the garbage,
but maybe we'd appreciate each other
more if we all took out the garbage once
a month.
No Way,
man.
I disagree with that.
That's what they're in Venezuela
by the way.
They're doing,
they're forcing people to be civil,
to be farmers for like 60 days out of
the year.
Something like that.
But I make them feel good about farmers
know,
cause like Venezuela's fucking imploding
and they need like Dan but,
but um,
I'll tell you man,
any time the government or federal
workers get more power in whatever way
it may be,
that's a bad thing for all of us.
And I think that the,
the,
the more we can push their fucking
tendrils out of our consciousness the
better.
And so anytime anyone is suggesting some
new,
I don't care how fucking utopian it
sounds.
Anytime anyone.
Here's the thing.
Do you think the government is corrupt?
If the answer is yes,
why would you want to give them more
power?
What would you want to give them more
tax planning.
Yeah.
Yes.
Why?
There's no,
now when you're talking about taxing
people,
you're not talking about giving them
money directly to the poor people,
right?
You know?
Yeah,
man.
Talking about going to the government
and the government distributes it with
no receipt.
Right?
Man,
that's what they do right now.
Yeah.
We don't want that.
That's fucked up.
If these people up there,
if they were like,
somehow we actually just imagine,
here's a crazy fantasy.
I don't know how you'd implement it,
but let's imagine we had a system where
every four years,
some of the coolest,
smartest people in the country became
our leaders.
Wow.
That would be fucking insane.
Coolest,
smartest people don't want that job just
by nature.
So it's a strange job.
The idea of wanting to be the person
that's in control of everything,
and I think until it goes horribly
wrong,
we're going to stay on the outside and
we're going to go hug somebody.
Come on somebody,
come on somebody.
I'll tell you,
man,
I think some of the coolest,
smartest people because they're so cool.
If I'm just saying,
this is a mystery,
how to get to them,
but let's just say you could.
That's a mystery.
How you get to them,
let's say,
and let's imagine there was what?
Who are they?
You don't even know the name of a
person,
but gave me the attributes you would
want to.
I would take somebody like Elon Musk.
I would take somebody like you.
I would take somebody.
Why not?
I would take somebody like,
I'm so,
I don't want the job.
What?
I don't want to judge you on.
Doesn't either.
All right,
fine,
but we all sit together in a room and
we're like,
hey man,
let's imagine like five more fat acids,
right?
We all sit together in a room and we
say,
listen,
I know none of you guys wanted this
fucking job.
You're successful because you're super
smart and you're super cool and you're
having great lives,
but would you consider for a couple of
years helping us work this shit out so
the planet gets a little better and I
guaranteed.
Now again,
this is a fantasy,
but I guarantee that there'll be very
few people in that room.
You'd be like,
no,
I'm going to live my life.
You'd be like,
yeah,
I'll do it for two years.
No problem.
How do for four years?
Sure.
I would love to help and still for four
years you go into this job truly
thinking,
man,
I'm going to see if I can reduce the
number of people who are fucking
uneducated and hungry and the bombs
going off and I'm going to try to do it
by using all of my smartest friends and
I'm not doing it because I'm going to
get money from this group or that group.
I'm doing it because it feels like the
right thing to do.
Do you know what that's called,
man?
That's called the American fucking dream
that the founding fathers came up with.
That was the idea.
We're going to have a group of
brilliant,
wonderful people who want this
particular swath of human beings to be
peaceful.
What is it?
A peaceful place where you can
experience life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness,
right?
Freedom,
autonomy,
community,
all of these beautiful things.
That was the idea,
beautiful idea.
It will almost make you cry when you
think about how beautiful a fucking idea
that is.
And then to imagine that that idea over
the course of time was gradually
deteriorated,
gradually infiltrated,
gradually broken down.
And of course it was because when there
is a powerful empire,
the empire is inevitably attacked by
entities that want to take it over.
Of course,
it's the nature of things.
Something powerful,
some asshole wants that power.
And so an analysis of the system over
the course of time or in an intentional
infiltration by people who have all the
money or just some systemic degradation,
a slow sort of collapse of a million
different systems inside the thing has
happened that has happened and yet the
concept remains one of the most
beautiful ideas,
one of the most incredible fucking
ideas.
They cannot erode the concept.
Well maybe it can still be saved with
technology.
Maybe the transparency that's being
afforded by technology is going to
somehow or another step in and put a
halt to what we see as just a standard
operational behavior of corruption and
influence,
corruption and influences.
Just so standard that it's right in
front of us.
When CNN is printing Hillary Clinton's
annual earnings for the past two years
is $21 million and no one's baton and I,
she's sitting there with a bite suit.
She has that bite suit on,
looks like a fucking German shepherds
going to jump out of the bushes and grab
her suit.
She walks around these boxy bite suit
and she's,
she's making ungodly sums of money from
just talking and she's doing it,
doing it,
doing it right in front of our face.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean that's one of the beautiful
things about Bernie Sanders,
one of the most beautiful things he
says,
I didn't take a dime from those people.
I don't speak to the banks because what
did you,
what did you say when you got paid?
Half a million plus or whatever she got
paid to speak.
How much did she get paid to speak to
the banks?
Because there was something fucking
bananas about that one.
There was one of the ones that she got
paid.
I made,
it might've been the 250 million now
release.
Yeah,
there's a bunch you want release.
She won't release the ones who she talks
to banks,
they'll get released,
they speak in Latin,
they get together.
They fucking burn baby snakes.
My lyrics virologically I started
talking in tongues and ship summary.
[inaudible] they're all eyes wide.
Shut it out.
Yeah.
Hoods on and fucking candle light
pentagrams everywhere.
Yeah,
man,
you,
they pro I wouldn't be fucking surprised
if there's a few things they do that we
might consider to be a little abnormal
when they get together.
Bohemian Grove,
look,
whatever the fuck they're doing,
their whatever they they do it for,
for whatever reason they really do.
Or at least used to dress up in robes
and burn an effigy in front of a fucking
giant owl statue.
Okay.
There's a video of it.
It's real for them.
They say it's fun and it's just like a,
uh,
one of those frat pranks or traditions
that people do,
although dress up in weird costumes and
they go through some weird skull and
bones ceremony that their grand pappy
did and everybody does it.
Cause you want to be,
what does that,
what is it called?
Pledged.
You want to be pledged?
Initiated.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on man.
This is,
there's a real video of these fucking
multimillionaire guys meeting in
Bohemian Grove and burning these fit.
Look at that.
Hillary Clinton was paid $225,000
to speak at Goldman Sachs builders and
innovators,
conference builders and innovative at
the Ritz Carlton Dove Mountain Resort
and Marina,
Arizona.
That is a Golfer's paradise.
All those rich dudes out there golfing
drive in those convertible Mercedes is
with the metal tops close and open and
like 13 seconds.
Yeah.
These,
these guys are,
look,
they're all fucking monsters.
You know,
man,
I,
I'll tell you,
this is something that I was thinking,
and by the way,
I'm sorry,
I did a fucking seemingly patriotic
spiel.
I didn't know that was inside of it.
It's,
well,
it is patriotic,
but it's,
it's you.
You are right.
These people were massively repressed by
Europe.
They took this incredible chance of
getting in boats and coming across an
ocean in the time where we're navigating
things with something that looks like a
protractor.
I mean the,
the,
he had sextants and other staring at the
fucking constellations trying to figure
out which way to go.
They're manipulating the air and get
there.
It's fucking amazing.
And a lot of them are doing that because
they want to worship God in a certain
way that they're not able to show you
where they're coming from.
But even even whatever their rationale
for leaving,
they still had the balls to get on a
fucking boat and make cross the ocean.
So that puts them in a better place in
my eyes.
Then those pussies that stayed back and
believed in logic but lived under the
rule of the queen.
Yeah,
those dummies are the king.
Was it came back then?
Probably probably a kings.
But my point is I don't have a point,
but if I had a point,
what would it would be?
That's the reason why America is so
fucking bad ass that at least at least
the
of the initial instincts to start it
still exist.
Yeah.
The idea can't go away.
It's a,
it's like a geometric form.
It,
here's the problem man.
Okay,
this is why it's thinking.
So let's imagine that you and I are
somehow,
I don't know why we end up on a cruise
ship filled with idiots like literal
fucking idiots fricking happen.
Somehow they just like,
they went through like maybe like some,
it's like the opposite of a reality show
where you find a great person like over
the course of like months,
they find like the world's worst people,
right?
And so are the world's like maybe like
the world's most unwise people are the
world's dumbest people.
So you end up in with like a population
of like 60 idiots on the boat.
And I'm not saying we're not idiots.
I certainly don't consider myself to be
a MENSA member,
but,
but let's imagine we're a little like
more on the ball and these guys are
right,
the boat fucking racks.
We're on an island now we have to build
a civilization.
How does democracy become a good thing
if the majority of people are kind of
not that fucking on point,
right?
What happens if,
um,
what if it's a,
let's imagine it's a boat filled with
psychotics.
Let's imagine it's a boat filled with
people who are paranoid schizophrenia
for example.
How do you have a democracy of paranoid
schizophrenia,
six running things.
And so when you have the news spraying
out a paradigm that is also weirdly
corrupt in the sense that the news is
being run by a groups of people who want
to sell advertising and need to be
entertaining.
And you know,
they have to at least present this
information and it kind of entertaining,
possibly warped way.
There are cases including in the recent
wikileaks,
uh,
dump that,
where the,
uh,
where they were the,
in the,
what's it called,
the ndd that in the nondisclosure
agreement with the national,
the Democratic Group,
the DNC,
the DNC was telling,
giving like talking points to the press,
right?
So if the media is painting a picture of
the universe that is not accurate or is
warped a little bit based on consumerism
or the corporations that are running
things,
then the people who have tuned into that
reality and believe it to be true,
you could safely say they are mildly
psychotic because they have bought into
a reality tunnel that might not actually
exist.
In which case is a democracy at that
point.
A good thing.
If the people living in the democracy
have for a lifetime,
been getting bad information,
shot into their fucking brains,
marijuana,
I'll give you brain damage wars.
Good.
Sometimes you just need to fucking kill
people.
We have got to get into fucking Iraq
because Saddam Hussein has weapons of
mass destruction that he is going to UN
leash on the fucking West.
Wrong information.
But if you believe it,
you believe wrong information,
and if you believe wrong information,
then that means that you are no longer
walking along the path that is there,
but a path created by other people.
Right?
So that's when democracy gets really
interesting because now what we have is
very powerful hypnotic cobbles of con,
of,
of billionaires sending bad information
to the population and attempt to shift
their perceptual mechanisms in such a
way that they will elect leaders that
don't represent them,
but that have been created by these
machines to take over the world.
And in that case,
the democracy becomes a little bit more
problematic.
So that's another problem.
It's like,
okay,
great.
Now let's imagine we suddenly have a
functioning democracy.
What if a lot of people in that function
functioning democracy have subscribed to
ideas that don't,
that aren't real,
and that they're not willing to let go
of?
Are you writing down?
Never put,
Duncan is showing you.
You'll know how to remember something.
I keep forgetting and I have to remember
it.
You just,
I don't want to stop your rant.
Oh,
cool.
Just,
you know when you're high as fuck like
we are right now so great and we start
talking about stuff.
When you're talking,
I have an idea but it just,
I have to follow your idea and my idea
slips away.
I had to write it down.
It's just that the idea is what if this,
what if not many of us like the shit we
believe ain't real and what if that shit
that we think is real has been
intentionally placed into our heads by
corporations with the intention of
making us behave in a certain way.
At that point a democracy becomes
problematic.
Like what are you going to do if you
mean there's so many people right now
who believe the like trump is putting
out a reality tunnel.
Hillary Clinton's putting out a reality
tunnel.
These are two different reality tunnels
where many of the pieces of it might not
actually reflect what's happening in the
world.
So it's like,
which of these made up stories are you
going to tune into or are you going to
reject both of them and go wandering off
into the woods alone and try to,
in your own way,
understand what's happening minus the
influence of the corporate media.
I was thinking when we're talking about
people coming over in boats that we were
talking earlier about the human biome
and uh,
your,
your gut biome in particular,
it affects your mood,
your intelligence level,
your personality,
it affects your immune system.
And that is,
that's one thing that I've been really
getting into over the last few years is
really concentrating on probiotics
first.
Kombucha,
that was the big one.
I liked that.
A gts Kombucha.
I like that original flavor.
It's like a,
it's almost like,
it feels like someone blew their nose in
it.
Those slimy slugs,
those,
uh,
Combu just slugs.
You gotta throw it down,
but it's really good for your immune
system.
And it made a big difference with all my
travel on the road.
But then I started really getting into,
Kiefer,
started really getting into a,
I drink goat's milk keifer several times
a week and I drink whole glass of it and
man,
it,
I,
the more I have been constantly on that
Kimchi.
That's another one that I've really
gotten into lately.
Um,
fermented cabbage.
it's a,
it's really good for you,
very probiotic as well.
The more I'm doing this,
like I feel happier,
if that makes any sense.
It actually makes me feel better.
Yeah.
I don't just feel like healthier in
terms of my immune system's really good,
but I feel better.
So what I was thinking is these poor
folks that got on that boat and came
across the seas.
When you think about the horrible
atrocities committed by the pilgrims or
the Columbus,
his soldiers,
yes.
When they came over here,
I mean,
they buy one account of a missionary.
They were dashing babies' heads on rocks
and were cutting people's arms off.
They didn't bring back their weight in
gold.
Right.
There was some really dark,
dark,
dark shit going on.
I wonder if it was a combination of
obviously barbaric human beings in
barbaric times when things were just way
fucking different and it was very little
accountability for psychopathic behavior
and in fact you hired these fucking
psychopaths,
these abused people,
murders.
There's,
there's are your soldiers cause your
people,
you're hiring,
you know,
those are the people that you put on
that fucking boat.
Those are the only people that are
willing so they get across his ocean.
It takes months.
Right.
How long did it take?
Get across seat,
find that out.
I'm going to say three months.
Do you think it took three months?
I don't know.
I'm going to say it took like 90 days.
I would think longer than that.
Really,
man.
Probably right.
Maybe four months.
What do you think?
Four months?
I don't know.
Like I feel like three months to do it.
If you knew what you were doing,
you got to get the right wins.
I mean it's like,
well you definitely might not make it.
And I like it says approximately two
months,
two months quick.
It started in early August and got there
October 12th wow.
God.
That's so ballsy.
Took approximately two months.
Christopher Columbus started his voyage
in Palos Spain in early August of 1492
with three ships,
the Nina,
the Pinta,
Santa Maria.
We all know that stuff.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Q madge and just being on that boat,
being a fucking fly on the wall on that
boat,
watching those murderers sail across the
ocean and knowing one day you're going
to get a day off school for those cunts.
No Shit.
We think of that.
There's these showed up,
but they just raped and murdered
everybody.
We get a day off school for him.
Pray,
pray,
praying along the way.
Long weekend,
we're going to have a suit coming.
Whoo.
Again.
There you go.
Yeah.
The fucking information that we have
does not accurately reflect reality.
Right.
We have been conditioned intentionally
by a power structure to believe in a
reality tunnel that if you don't believe
in that reality tunnel,
you're considered to be somebody who's a
little crazy.
Yeah,
your fucking mind.
Columbus was a good man.
What are you fucking talking about?
I remember that commercial where the
guy's eating salad and his friends
going,
what do you mean if I buy drugs?
You sports.
How?
Terrorism,
right.
Fact,
right that he's eating salad.
He's a no nonsense kind of steak bar.
Remember that?
Because it's a fact.
I say it because of the fact that's it.
The Guy Guy's like standing there like
it's that relationship that we all know
of that one fucking super good arguing,
right wing guy that's a little bit older
and the other guy and he kind of clowns
them when they have lunch together.
Come on,
get your shit together Mike.
Okay,
we're going to make the loan go through
but straighten out your credit.
That's the same guy because you're
supporting terrorism is the fact is
eating a salad or say cause it's fact.
Yet there's something cycle.
Just like a mind fuck going on.
Cause we know that relationship.
We know that paradigm which wean the
really fucking straight up Republican,
no nonsense.
Got His shit together,
has a cigar and a single malt scotch.
And that's about it.
And we know and that other guy who's
like,
Hey,
I heard that tower seven is a,
is an inside job.
What?
Yeah,
don't say that eating is lettuce or tell
him fuck.
It's not true.
It's not true because it's a fact.
You can,
I know without saying it's a bad
example,
but that thing that people like to do,
it's a fat little fuck man.
I mean yeah that it's a fact fucking guy
is our version of a person who has been,
it happens in North Korea.
There's that like,
I don't know if you saw it but like in
one of these documentaries about North
Korea,
which I love to watch cause it's the
ultimate example.
If a hypnotize culture when you submit
ultimate and it's right now right now,
which is insane when you consider what
the past could have been like.
We never,
we don't have a window.
We don't have a window into what gingiss
Khan's empire was like.
We don't have a window to Mao's China.
We don't have a window to that,
but we have a window right now.
A fucking physical window of real video.
This is it.
This is the guy does a no nonsense guy
play the commercial.
I love this crash will go from the
beginning to it from the beginning.
Yeah.
These bells,
it drug money,
funds,
terror.
It's a ploy.
Manipulation.
Got Jamie.
Why should I believe that?
New to the Internet,
he's got several tabs going at the same
time.
You're going to hear him moaning soon
because he's got his porn.
It's a ploy.
It's drug money,
funds,
terror.
It's deploying Laurie manipulation like
he's eating drug money,
ploys,
terror.
I mean why should I believe that?
Because it's a fat,
fat,
fat.
So you're saying that I shouldn't
believe it because it's true.
That's,
that's your argument.
It is true.
This is the dumbest fucking
conversation.
Cause I want to jump in there and I say,
okay,
well tell me how that's true.
Let me give me some specifics.
I talk to you about money funds to her.
Can I tell you it's true?
If you're,
yeah,
you're the guy.
I'm the other guy.
Here's how it's true.
Okay.
So,
um,
many of the people who are currently in
the u s government have taken lots of
money from the pharmaceutical companies
that supply some of the most dangerous
drugs on earth to people all over the
planet.
And,
and,
and those people in the government are
also in charge of dropping bombs on
people in other parts of the world.
Stop you right there.
They also made Viagara and the pill.
That's great.
Okay.
That was great.
Oh,
choose Viagara don't you like the pill?
Drugs?
Don't you like to shoot loads and you
grow without any consequences?
Yes,
I know.
We all do have,
that's funding terrorism.
Every time you shoot a load into your
girl,
that's fun.
Are you sure?
Is it a fact?
Is it an fmct fat dude?
Terrorism?
Fuck.
I'll tell you.
Fucking terrorism.
Terrorism is every time.
I mean,
when you start hearing the civilian
casualties in Syria and all over the
fucking place,
show you something.
I'm going to show you something.
Go back a few days on my,
um,
my twitter feed.
I retweeted this Syrian girl who was a
praying,
oh,
I saw it.
I saw her.
Safety.
You've seen it.
Right.
Again,
if you want to horrify the fucking
audience,
but I'd rather not watch it again.
Okay,
well let's just describe what it is.
Um,
you could,
you can go watch yourself.
Forget it Jamie.
He's gonna Freak out.
I was ready to cry.
I'm ready to cry.
It's horrible.
There's a guy and he's talking to his
daughter and she's reciting a prayer and
apparently she's reciting some prayer of
safety and while they're doing it,
you here and they both get shot like
rocketed back and forth.
Like something hit near their building.
You see like the reverberations,
the impact move them.
They,
they jut out of the frame and then the
video stops.
It's terrifying.
I mean,
look,
it might not even be real.
I'm,
I'm assuming it's real.
It might not even be real,
but it,
cause I don't know,
I can't verify it.
But that happens exactly the way you're
looking at it.
Whether or not that is an actual
representation or whether or not
somebody wants you to imagine what it
would be like.
I don't know.
I don't know the veracity.
I haven't,
I haven't studied the video.
I don't know.
Have you,
do you know whether or not anybody's
calling bullshit on that video?
Well,
look,
I mean it's,
yeah,
they do bond.
Exactly.
But I'm not sure if you're seeing that
or if it's one of the,
you know,
there's a,
there's a company that was a,
I think it's an Australia that uh,
they create fake viral videos to get
hits and they're a special effects
company and they've,
they're responsible for like a gang of
amazing videos that have been online.
One of them was this,
a couple that shot a lion and then you,
you see the lion,
uh,
another line there.
They're standing over taking pictures.
Yeah.
This one special effects group made that
and a bunch of other fake ones too,
that a lot of people sent me and they
said they were real and I retweeted them
like,
oh wow,
that's crazy.
You know,
but meanwhile these people are just
special effects artists.
Cool.
The line one didn't get me,
I was like,
this is too perfectly framed.
It's too good.
It got me,
didn't get me at all.
Plus,
I didn't like the way that the line,
the way it was looking though.
It was sitting there on the ground.
It looked fake.
The whole thing looked like it looked
like a fake lie.
But then there's one that came out today
that I'm a reasonably sure is real.
And this one I was telling you about
before the show,
but there's a bear in this guy's house
and uh,
he looks downstairs in my friend Shane
Carwyn actually tweeted a picture.
I've got a retweet it when I find it.
He tweeted me a picture today of a
fucking bear that broke into his
friend's cabin and tore it apart.
Tore the,
uh,
the frigerator open,
ripped out everything on the floor,
ripped out cabinets,
just tore his fucking place bar.
And apparently his friend called Shane
is like,
ah,
hey dude,
did you uh,
use my cabin or something?
Cause I know Shane Collins is giant
heavyweight UFC fighter.
He's a former,
uh,
UFC interim heavyweight champion.
He's a gorilla.
And so his friend,
like that's the first person he called.
Imagine if someone tears through your
house,
Richard Fucker,
refrigerated door off the wall,
this foot plate waste like they eat
someone just fucking hulked out in your
kitchen.
So they call Shane up for is hey dude,
um,
my cabin rip my refrigerator door off.
And then there was another one.
That's true as well.
It's real where a bear got trapped in
someone's car,
somehow know that the bear opened the
car door,
which they've been known to do.
If you leave it open,
look at that.
That's a bear trap in the back of that
fucking Subaru poor guy.
I wonder how long and he's in there for,
it's a good question.
I think they were walking by and they
found them.
So what a bear does is they know,
they figured out over time that they can
open car doors.
If they open up a car door,
they watch someone open up a car door,
I'll get another bear.
And then there's food in there.
That's it from then on there opening car
doors.
So while when I was in boulder,
one of the people that lived in the town
over from where I lived,
got their car broken into and the bear
ate the inside of their car.
The bear,
I mean literally ate their seats.
Eight,
their dashboard,
Dan,
the crazy sucks.
So this bear is trapped in this guy's
car.
This is 100% legit.
So you opens up the car door with his
paws,
climbs inside.
And you know,
like if a car is like at a kind of an
angle,
the door will close itself.
Door closes itself.
He's like,
Whoa,
just stuck in his car.
Just mangling it.
Look at it,
look at the chair,
torn apart.
Probably shitting all over the
dashboard.
I'm good.
I'm right here.
I wonder if their insurance coverage,
I wonder if anybody's got a bow and
Arrow coming to make some bare sausage
son.
Uh,
you gotta let him out.
I means that's fucked up.
Shoot an animal inside a car.
That's not fair.
Chase.
I'm joking around.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I would definitely let them out,
but I'd be fucking pissed because this
car is just shot.
It's mangled.
You can open up your trunk with a,
uh,
a key and with some people does that,
what they did,
did they open up the bag and let him
out?
What's happening here?
How can the hatches open areas just ran
off and he's running off.
That was a pretty decent sized bear yet.
What kind of damage did it do?
Pretty peaceful man.
Bears always seem like they run,
they tend to run for sure.
Right?
Until they kill you.
Yeah.
You say,
oh,
it's peaceful.
It's peaceful.
Do you know more people get killed by
black bears then by grizzlies?
No.
Did Not.
It's
weird.
Grizzlies a lot of times the key by
accident like a,
you stumble upon the mom and the cubs,
right?
Black bears apparently will actively
seek people sometimes when they're
really desperate.
Oh my God,
man.
That is,
fuck.
There's a bear.
My neighbor had suppose how's the past
dean of bears are eating garbage and
stuff or having a good old time and
swimming pools and shit.
You don't have to worry about them.
You got to worry about,
um,
predatory bear.
It's like there's a guy that I know
steve or Hosa show meter.
One of his friends took a guy out
hunting for his very first time they
were camping and a 500 pound predatory
black bear climb.
The 10 attacked him in the middle of the
night and his friends shot the bear.
The bullet went through the bear and
shot his friend in the wrist so he got
shot.
He got bit by a bear is first hunting
trips cause arrest.
Bullet shattered his wrist,
went through the baron shatters wrist.
That's tough man.
Whenever you have those kinds of bad
lucks land on top of each other,
like the balloon accident where like not
only do you fall to your death,
but you're also on fire while you fall
to your death.
17 people.
Terrible fuck hot air balloons,
dude.
Fuck,
fuck.
Being in the sky with fire and cloth.
Never.
What about a hard breeze?
What happens if this bitch gets hit by
lightning?
Huh?
You ever fucking monkeys?
I watched the video.
That guy jumping out of the plane.
Yes.
Yes,
I did.
Insane.
10th insane.
And by the way,
he didn't even hit it in the middle.
He hit the edge.
I mean,
I'm sure it's a huge fucking net,
but not huge enough.
Like how you judging that correctly when
you're coming down at who knows how fast
he's coming down.
He lays there for a second until like
he's stunned or sad.
A flip over before impact.
She was practicing flipping over like he
had otherwise his face is going to get
shredded,
right?
He's got to land on his back.
So this guy's going down and then right
before he hits the bottom,
he flips.
So he's got to like guide himself with
his own fucking arms and he hosted,
he doesn't splatter.
That's his gopro man.
I mean,
how is he possibly going to judge this?
he has some sort of a,
a like a wingspan thing going on,
whereas his legs are spread.
Now Watch this,
she falls over,
he turns over right before the end and,
and lands in the net.
What in the actual fuck.
And everybody's applauding.
It's Bobby Collins and Whoopi Goldberg.
They're,
they're,
they're both selling.
Hey,
almost doug.
He's,
he's,
he's crying.
Oh dude,
it mom,
this girl's got big tits.
Come here.
Take a look at these teds before.
Hey,
this guy will get his deck.
Why they have these people?
Look at this.
We are here live on the scene.
He didn't die.
It's amazing.
This is the first time ever a person did
this and lived.
We're so happy.
We're so happy we could broadcast this
on television.
It's so important.
Look at,
yes
we do,
dude.
We did it.
You crazy fuckers.
All of you.
Oh my God.
Cause you know if that shit didn't work
out,
oh my God,
the net broke and for the rest of your
life,
you have to remember that the what that
looks like a just the explosion Godson,
the,
that sound that's going to make,
when that thing hits the fucking tarmac,
his wife's screaming or just a silent
scream.
Just everyone.
Just Ptsd.
You're going to have to go to a
therapist to get that out of your head.
You're going to wake up with the memory
of that guy's body just exploding like a
fucking watermelon in front of you.
What if the pressure of the situation,
the gravity of the situation,
the,
the adrenaline rush and the g force all
combined made him stroke out like that
Indian dude and he just never even
bothered steering and went right into
the crowd.
Oh Man.
Like a human messel just took out kids
and fucking grandma crushed a subaru
scraps of bloody gatorade color jumpsuit
landing on your kid.
Imagine if you died because this guy hit
the ground and his skull went flying
through the air and hit you in the face
and crush your head.
You got your head crushed from his
forehead.
Or even worse,
you don't die.
You just get like amputated.
No,
you just have like neurological problems
for the rest of your life.
Like you like,
you know,
like someone is in a car accident and
you go into a temporary when he come out
you,
you shit yourself for the rest of your
life and people ask why?
It's like a skydiver skull smashed into
me.
Terrible man.
Fuck Dude.
High impact.
Avoid that.
What high impact?
High impact.
Avoid that.
Don't jump out of those planes into
nuts.
Stop.
Are they going to get fucking cte from
net falling?
Imagine if that becomes a new thing.
What's what kind of cte,
chronic traumatic,
chronic traumatic encephalopathy and
stuff.
So brain damaged the football players
get,
I would imagine the jolt of going from
space into a fucking net is
considerable.
Yeah,
sure.
I would imagine that that has an impact
on your fucking don't easy on your
fucking body to fall out of a plane in
anything.
It's definitely not what you,
by the way,
man.
Speaking of like fucked up like sports
accidents and I know you get sick of
talking about the UFC,
but dude,
that fucking clip of,
what's his name?
Cyborg.
What's the guy's name?
The guy that when I bought Santos is a
bunch of cyborgs.
There's a two male cyborgs and one
female,
so it makes sense.
It's a cool word,
but I was thinking man,
that thing he did the knee kick flying
knee kick smashed.
The guys handled.
Ever say knee kick.
Don't ever say,
what'd he say?
It's a knee flying knee.
You don't see a knee kick.
Guys,
listen to my voice.
Do I sound like I know a lot about the
USC,
a little Moitai back in the,
well,
my
trainer taught me some.
But anyway,
the point is,
is it possible,
you know,
k basketball people are getting better
at basketball,
right?
Skateboarding people are getting better
at skateboarding.
Is it possible that in the UFC people
are going to become so proficient at
beating each other up that it,
there will be more of this type of awful
accident happening where people just
learn how to be powerful enough to crush
a person's skull where you just get
better at it,
man.
Like if you look at like,
and it's not a fair comparison because
this Pa skateboard you,
it requires a tool.
But if you look at like early
skateboarding videos to now and see how
much it's evolved and you know,
the UFC has the market pressure for
these fighters to be the best ever
because they become like world renowned
fighters and they make a lot of money.
So the pressure is there to evolve.
If you look at UFC 100 years from now,
isn't it possible that fighters are
going to get so good that it is no
longer safe to do the UFC because
they're just going to be strong enough
to break someone's skull open with their
fucking fists or with their knees?
Well,
let me answer that.
First of all,
it was a very unusual scenario where a
guy was diving forward and the other guy
was jumping forward with the name and
they combined in a perfect collision.
Right.
It's very unusual to happen that way.
It's happened before though.
Um,
it,
it does happen.
It can happen.
But that was the most extreme version of
ever seen in my life.
And all my years of watching martial
arts,
watching martial arts training and
martial arts,
seeing fights,
I don't know how many fights I've seen
live,
but it's gotta be more than a thousand.
It's probably what,
sure.
It's probably like 1500 or something
like that live.
I've never seen it once.
I only watched it once on TV.
So,
um,
guys have definitely gotten their nose
broken though.
And they've definitely gotten their
orbits broken.
The orbit broken,
orbital,
orbital a bone is super common.
That's real common.
That happens all the time.
That happens like once a year.
I mean in the,
in that sense of calm and more,
maybe even more than that.
We don't hear about it.
Maybe they're small fractures,
but like Misha tate,
the former women's bantamweight
champion,
she got her orbital bone broken in a
fight.
Um,
Bob psats ha.
He had Bob Sapp had his orbital bone
broken in by cro cop.
Uh,
I can name a bunch of them were guys who
have gotten their orbital broken.
It's really common.
So,
uh,
that's your face.
You're getting your face broke.
It,
this is just a different version of it.
And it was such an extreme impact.
Michael Venom page,
the guy who did it is a,
a sport karate champion and a really
dynamic guy.
He's so fucking fast and his technique
is so good.
His timing is so good.
He's a lifelong martial artists who was
competing as a point karate guy.
And then he went from being a point
karate guy to fighting and mma and he
can hit guys in this crazy way,
dives in and hits them and they can't
him back.
And when they were running at him,
he counters them brilliantly.
And that's what he did in this fight.
Cyborg who's talented guy who has been
around a long time,
he's really experienced,
he's fought in strikeforce.
He fought in the UFC and the UFC.
I feel like he did.
I'm almost positive he did.
Um,
Google that though please.
Cause I know he fought in strikeforce.
He had an epic fight with Nick Diaz and
strike force and Jordan Meehan and
strike force epic epic fights.
So he's a real veteran.
And uh,
to have this happen to him is even more
impressive.
It just shows you how good this page kid
is.
But um,
it's so unusual the way it happened.
I've never seen it like that before
where a guy just charged in and the
other guy didn't hit,
just hit him with the need put jumped at
him.
So you'd have to have Michael Venom
pages,
athleticism,
technique,
experience,
lifelong martial artist.
Perfect timing.
And then also fight intelligence.
Like he had the intelligence to choose
that weapon.
He has a full arsenal of techniques.
He knew that that would be the most
effective blow to land in that moment.
So all his lifelong experience of
competing as a martial artist led to
that moment.
So it was a perfect storm for cyborgs
head.
The wrong the wrong thing at the wrong
time.
And it can always happen just like Dale
earnhardt junior or senior died in a car
accident.
It can happen like the,
the,
even the great ones can get really badly
hurt.
But,
but you could see it like,
I mean,
I'm sure you've seen it over those 1500
fights you've seen having,
you seen an evolution in the fighting
styles,
but on both sides.
The other thing is I've seen an
evolution in people's defense too,
but there's guys like mighty mouse who
like barely get hit,
right.
You know,
and he,
and he's beating guys up,
but occasionally you'll get a guy who is
like an elite guy and another guy is an
elite guy and always cancel each other
out.
People get mad,
people get mad because it's not an of
action cause they're both two smart and
they kind of like canceling each other.
That does happen.
That happens in fights.
So I just think that everybody is
definitely getting better,
but their defense is getting better as
well.
And it's just,
it's a sport where it's so chaotic and
anyone can win by knockout if they
connect and everyone is so fast and
everyone has so much technique that the
best guys can knock out the best guys.
We saw it this weekend.
Matt Brown,
who is like one of the top UFC
welterweight in the world,
he's a fucking animal savage.
One of my favorite fighters ever fought
this kid named Jake ellenberger.
Yeah.
Jake ellenberger is a very talented
guys,
had ups and downs,
but he's lost a bunch of fights recently
to top level guys.
And this was his last chance in the UFC.
They gave him a last chance.
They said,
you know,
they were gonna cut him and he said,
just give me one more fight.
And they said,
okay,
we're going to give you matt Brown who's
a demon.
And he's like,
okay.
So he went in and knocked out Matt Brown
the first round,
but it was crazy.
It was a crazy chaos filled fight.
He blasted him with a right hand and
kicked him the body with a liver kick
and put them away.
It was an madness fight.
And even Matt Brown was even coming back
after getting hit with the first big
punch.
But my point is,
on any given night,
one of these guys connect and they can
knock out the other guy.
They can both do it.
Matt Brown easily could've knocked out
ellenberger right?
Easily could have connected sales.
It's,
it's possible for all these guys to
knock each other out.
So it's a nutty sport man.
So they're definitely getting better at
it,
but they're all getting better.
So it's harder to hit him clean and
they're better at delivering shots.
Well,
if one person gets better,
then everyone's going to adapt to come
up with some defense for whatever.
The thing is.
That person's gotten better at,
I guess.
But he did learn the techniques,
they learn the techniques and they
understand when the,
when they're coming.
But if you had to predict,
like if someone's,
like,
if you had to predict five years from
now,
what kind of,
if you've seen a kind of evolution in
that fighting styles,
then you've,
you've seen an something that maybe you
can prognosticate in five years,
what do you,
what do you think it's going to look
like?
How will it be different?
How will the UFC change over time if
mixed martial arts is an evolving sport?
Well,
we already know pretty much I would say
there's always room for new stuff.
It's always possible the new stuff comes
out.
But I would comfortably say we know at
least 95% of all the striking options
were pretty,
pretty well versed in what a person can
do with their bones.
And I'm being real conservative.
When I say 95% is probably closer to 99%
but every now and then someone will do
something crazy.
Like this guy,
uh,
I don't know the name of the
organization,
but just knock some guy out with an ax
kick the other day.
And somebody sent it to me and I was
like,
Ooh,
see if he could find that ax kick Kayo
and mma.
It's real recent.
This is the first time I've seen that in
a televised MMA bow.
But I saw it a gang and times and
taekwondo tournament.
And I,
I,
I've witnessed it firsthand with a very
good friend of mine.
He got knocked out horribly by an ax
kick.
So I know that accidents are real
dangerous for guys good at them,
but you have to have elite flexibility
and speed and you have to know how to
land it.
And,
uh,
so that was a new one that up until this
year,
I don't think anybody knocked anybody
out with one before.
There was a guy named Adlon Ama golf who
was fighting in strikeforce and he
fought in the UFC for a little bit,
but he got real religious and he decided
to,
to quit fighting.
But I think he might've fuck somebody up
with an ax kick wants he had,
he had nasty,
nasty kicks.
But the point is that might've been the
last of the Mohicans as far as like new
techniques that you're going to see
people do.
Pretty much everything.
Round kicks,
sidekicks,
front kicks,
we already seen all those.
We already know they exist.
So that's pretty much covered.
But it's really getting,
what people are getting better at is
their ability to deliver those
techniques in a fluid form that's
imperceptive both for the person's
trying to anticipate the movements.
So like when someone is attacking you,
what it's like is say if you were a
really dumb guy and you were in a debate
about Chris with Christopher hitchens
about something that you really
shouldn't have been debating for about,
like you don't really don't know the
subject very well when you're talking
shit.
And he just starts with
is he's clinking his whiskey glass
around and touching it with his fingers
and just demolish his you on on real
time with Bill Maher.
Right?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Mean,
like Christopher hitchens could do to
any of it.
So fun to watch him do that.
Too.
Terrifying because you would think,
oh my God,
what if it was me?
What if I got up there and talk about
the Iraq war?
I,
you know what the fuck I'm talking about
me.
He is buried me.
Did you ever see when he buried most
def?
No,
he hurried them.
Most def was asking questions about al
Qaeda and the Taliban.
He didn't know the different in al Qaeda
and the Taliban.
I don't either.
And uh,
most def,
um,
was talking about it and Christopher
Hitchens to society was annoying and
just does distressed him.
Just undressed him.
Absolutely trust him downs at the word.
How's like depression.
I would almost rather get dragged off by
a tiger and have hitchins destroy me.
Fuck him,
Bill.
You're so ruthless about become a monk.
If that happened,
I'd be like,
well,
I'm just going away.
I'm going to find a little monastery and
just shave my head and say goodbye to
the universe.
Like there's some guys,
they can destroy you,
but you almost feel like a,
they're letting you off the hook.
Like Sam Harris.
Sam Harris destroys people in a very
calm way and he doesn't insult them.
Right.
But he does it very logically be lets
you know that he thinks you're retarded.
Right.
He wouldn't use those words,
but I do,
but,
but hitchins shows utter disdain for you
while he's scoring on it.
Harris seems like there's that hope
when,
yeah,
Hitchens is pissed.
Harris,
it feels more like,
at least there's the hope that he's
going to bring you to his side.
There's something compassionate in it,
but yeah.
Hitchins is like,
yeah,
hitchens is like,
well,
you just,
I might as well,
you can be part of the genocide that I
want to have happen to idiots of the
world.
And it's a really a really intense thing
to watch,
man.
He must,
he must've just constantly read.
Like that guy must've just woken up in
the morning and just started reading for
hours.
And it was definitely,
yes,
definitely not just smart,
but also well-read.
Yeah.
We all,
we all know people that are very smart,
but they don't read that much.
Right.
He was all the above smart,
well read and did a lot of debating and
had a lot of conversations with really
smart people,
which is a big part of it as well.
And you know,
and we're very lucky that we get to
listen to those because that's kind of
like having those conversations,
not in the sense that you're saying the
words,
but being privy to a conversation with a
guy like Hitchens,
like you see sitting there and talking
with Sam Harris or some a religious
leader or something like that in the,
the logical points that he makes,
it's,
they're,
they're very enriching in a way that a
lot of times,
like school isn't even,
a lot of times your professor is a
fucking incompetent cunt that got that
job because he sucked the right decks
and now he's got tenure.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those shitty repressors
man.
Yeah.
Did a lot of those,
there's a hitchens video.
Did you see the one where he talks about
what a monster Saddam Hussein wise and
you see now and oh yeah,
his genius.
Yeah,
and he's right.
You know,
I,
it was all my arm monster though.
Saddam Hussein,
he was our monster.
Sure.
Yeah.
We,
we helped that guy,
but his sons are even scarier.
They ever read some of the things that
his sons did.
I can't remember.
I,
his sons were like Ramsay Bolton from
the game of thrones.
But for real,
they fed women to dogs.
They would take a woman,
they would take her from her bridal
party,
raper killer husband or throw her
husband in jail raper and then feed her
to their dogs.
And they did this more than once.
God Damn,
man.
Yeah.
Well this is what we're talking about.
We were talking about like North Korea,
by the way.
I don't know that this happened.
I wasn't there.
This is what I heard and this is what he
could read it online.
That's what everybody has said.
It's pretty much agreed that he did it.
But I think again,
like I was criticizing you earlier,
I totally could be completely wrong,
but this guy,
if they did do it,
I'm pretty sure they did or something
like it.
They didn't do awesome stuff.
That was not that long ago,
man.
We did some awesome stuff.
You know,
like I bet it wasn't all feed and girls.
The dog was,
I bet they were complete total
sociopaths and psychopaths from the womb
there.
Dad was a murderer is dictator.
He raised them and I bet he raised them
to be fucking monsters.
No,
you're ready to romance book.
Who did,
how many sane jerk off to it?
I haven't read it yet.
I think they're releasing it soon.
Look at it and shit like there.
He wrote like a real,
a romantic piece of fiction.
I mean,
by the way,
I'm not saying that Hussein or bolt or
whatever the fuck is weird day Coosa
Uday and Qusay work.
But it is so fucking terrible when you
realize that even the worst people still
have something good about them did.
They're isn't a complete monster out
there.
Well,
there's definitely complete monsters.
So happened for sure.
I think that inside you don't think Ed
gain,
the guy used to make lampshades at a
women's skin do serial killer.
I think the monster is part of being
human being is that no matter how
fucking awful you are and no matter how
terrible,
now this could be completely naive and
I'm sure there's exceptions,
but mostly no matter how fucking off who
you are,
some little piece of you inside of you
glimmering way down there underneath all
the fucking violence and murder knows
that you have the potential to be kind
and it tortures you and I think that's
inside every single person.
You can feel it in you all the time,
no matter how good or how bad you are.
There's always that like you want to
help.
There's always something in there.
Even fucking Dahmer,
even the worst of the worst man,
somewhere in there.
There it's in.
It's in every single person.
It's what I think it's what we are.
And the more separate you get from it,
the more you start doing,
you know,
he would get,
it starts with like not putting your
fucking shopping cart away at the
grocery store.
The problem was we're talking about
people that aren't broken.
They're there.
There's people that through whatever
reason,
through nature or nurture,
there's people that have fuses broken.
Just like there's people that are born
with leukemia,
just like some people have cancer,
just like some people have epilepsy,
just like some people are born with
disfigured arms.
Some people's brains are fucking wired
wrong from the jump.
There's something wrong biologically
with them.
Okay,
sure.
Right.
I mean,
don't,
wouldn't we assume?
Yes,
I would.
I totally agree that there are people,
he's fucking,
brains aren't working,
but I don't think we're just our brains.
No,
I mean,
I don't think so either,
but I,
well that's what I'm saying.
Like it's not an either or.
It's not a nature or nurture.
It's probably all kinds of stuff going
on,
you know?
I mean,
I think some people are most likely born
with defective minds.
Right?
We all agree with that.
There was definitely people that have
uh,
challenged,
learning disabilities,
all sorts of issues and a dyslexia.
There's all sort of things that were
absolutely aware of.
Well there's got to be for sure some
shit that would lead a person to not
understand when they're causing other
people harm or not care or,
or like it,
this is what I mean,
is it sociopath?
Right?
See,
I like to believe that because okay.
And this is,
you know,
an infinite never ending argument.
Some people believe humans are meat
robots.
Self awareness comes from the sum total
of all these different processes running
at once.
And now we have this awareness of this
south,
whatever that may be.
Some people think that there is an
infinite never ending undying pixel that
is grow that a human has grown around
[inaudible] and I think goes on forever.
And that thing is I'm made of love or
for lack of a better word,
it is.
Um,
right.
So the idea is,
and I,
I like to believe this idea,
as crazy as it may sound,
anyone can be redeemed.
Redemption is possible for all humans
living today.
There is a way to stop your forward
momentum and the direction of
selfishness and start moving in the
direction of being a little bit less of
a fucking prick.
I believe maybe people that have the
inclination or they have the potential
to be a psychopath if they were raised
by kind and loving people would develop
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with civilization and with harmony and
community.
Like maybe what you get when you get a
psychopath is the combination of really
shitty upbringing,
child abuse,
all sorts of awful verbal and emotional
shit that happens.
People in physical shit that happens to
people in the young and these traits.
Yeah,
and also maybe maybe some of those
traits are triggered by genes expressing
themselves and time of great duress.
Yeah,
which is one of the things that I was
talking about that I forgot earlier.
I started on it,
but I never finished.
It was talking about the
people that came over on these boats.
They're their gut biome.
If we're talking about someone who is on
a boat for 60 days eating fucking beef
jerky and they come over here with
scurvy,
they're desperate.
They're fucking body's eating itself.
I mean,
literally their body's eating itself.
Yeah,
you're,
your bones are fucking weak.
Your lack of vitamin C is causing you to
get ill and then you land on this beach
and you're in an insane desperation mode
and you already a piece of shit.
Her height,
you're already a monster.
He already some monster from Europe and
you come over here with a fucking a free
past to wreak havoc.
These aren't even,
people look to Brown then don't look
anything like,
all right,
they get us gold.
Hey,
get that gold.
How do I,
how do you want me to get it?
Any way you can get it.
Okay.
I'm just cut that dude's arm off till he
gives me gold.
Right?
I mean,
what,
this is all what we know happened,
right?
Yeah.
When you're starving,
I wonder if you really are a different
person.
Like when you hear about people like
the,
um,
the people that came over on the,
the pass in Colorado,
the Donner party won a beat and each
other,
cause they fucking froze to death out
there and they,
they didn't know what to do and there
was no foods.
They just started hating each other.
Like what?
What is the switch that goes off like w
who are you when that happened?
So you even the same person,
right?
If you really are,
if your personality consists of this
ecosystem that we call your body,
which we know for a fact has all sorts
of different stuff that's going on.
There's different stuff on your skin,
there's different stuff in your body,
there's all sorts of different bacteria
that it coexists with you and even exist
in a symbiotic way,
right?
Like you need all these things inside
your body to consume the food.
Like it's part of your digestive system,
right?
He Kolai is a natural part of the human
digestive tract,
right?
It's all in there.
What,
what,
what are you,
when you're starving,
are you,
will you like some crazy wolf person?
Like,
what does a person like?
I mean,
what are they,
how,
how scary is someone when they're a day
from starving to death and they have a
knife?
Well,
man,
I mean this is the question of freewill
versus no free.
Well,
you're saying if you get in a stressful
situation,
does some kind of mechanism of the
swarms of organisms that make up
yourself kick in where you no longer are
capable of making decisions?
I mean,
do you even you,
you absolutely.
I it,
I don't think it ever goes away.
And I think that you always have this
weird autonomy that the universal try to
trick you into thinking isn't there and
then suddenly you become a,
um,
now of course though,
I think if you look at the,
uh,
judicial system,
there is a form of murder where you
don't,
a temporary insanity is what they call
it,
right?
Yeah.
So,
you know,
there's like people who have lost
their fucking mind and stabbed someone
to death,
they prove that in court.
And then in that case,
you don't even go to jail.
You've killed someone because you a
temporarily fucking insane.
But I don't know man.
I think that mostly,
mostly if you really watch yourself,
you realize that you're,
you're pretty much in control man.
Like your,
when I watch myself when I'm about to be
an asshole,
like if I'm about to do something cause
I'm hangry as they call it,
you're talking about the ultimate
version of hangry,
which is where your result to
capitalism,
hungry and tired,
angry,
hangry,
hungry and angry.
Hungry and angry.
So like,
uh,
yeah,
it's a good tired that's hired but,
but that's higher than a shitty job but,
but uh,
so,
but if you look at yourself even in
that,
when you're having like by a chemical
shit going down and you're about to say
something nasty to somebody usual or do
something nasty,
usually you're old,
you're like,
ah,
I'm about to,
um,
like do I give it into this horrible
impulse?
Yes.
Do I just shit all just open my ass hole
up and spray?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
I do.
I do it.
And then you do it,
then you do it.
You say,
you know what,
I'm going to fucking spray.
And it's,
it's just like coming to,
it was just like coming,
cause it's like when you're about to see
if you want this thing,
when you watch yourself about to have an
orgasm,
right?
And you watch it build and build and
build and build,
and eventually it gets to a point where
you're going to decide to come or you
can't control.
It may be and you're gonna fucking come,
but you can watch it build and build and
build.
But then when you come,
the orgasm is like a mild seizure of
joy.
Your body goes through these like,
ah,
there's a coal by though your entire
body as a reaction,
right?
So in the same way,
when you start getting angry,
it's just like when you're fucking about
to come,
it's building and building and building.
And then you're like,
you know what?
I'm going to fucking tell this person
how I really fucking feel to day.
But you're angry and then woof,
all this weird seizure shit happens.
Stuff comes out of your mouth that you
don't even mean.
It's like half real half.
Not Real.
So,
but you decide,
you decide when to squeeze the trigger.
It's not something that you don't have
control of,
at least mostly.
And people who fool themselves into
thinking that they don't have control,
those are the ones who I think relegate
themselves into the world of being some
kind of machine,
some kind of like victimy machine.
I,
right.
But you know,
that's not really the free will
argument.
Right.
You know,
the full free provable argument,
right?
I know some freewill arguments.
I get the most compelling one.
That determinism one w what's compelling
about it is that it doesn't exonerate
you from your decisions,
but what it does say is essentially to
think that you are somehow another
separate from the influence of
your life and that the influence of your
life hasn't in some way influenced the
way you decide to act and behave.
And that a lot of those factors that led
you influencing the way you act and
behave,
what led to you,
uh,
changing the way you act to behave are
completely out of your control and I'm
almost unavoidable in their impact and
that these things shape you in some in
measurable way that you'll never be
completely autonomous from.
You'll never be able to completely
separate yourself from the influence of
your genetics,
of your life experiences of your
neighborhood,
of your mom or your dad or your
upbringing,
the Dell velop mental period where you
may or may not have been ignored or
abused or all those factors play a part
in how you decide to behave and even how
you decide to deal with how you decide
to behave your own therapy.
Like if you decided,
hey man,
I'm tired of jizzing all over people
with my asshole.
Every time I buy temperature boils up,
at the end of the day I'm going to
figure out how to not come home from a
hard day's work at the factory and beat
my wife.
Like,
even that is potentially determined by
your past and not really,
you having free will decide not to be a
piece of shit.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
So the,
okay,
so
not my theory,
this is a,
this is more of a shitty explanation of
what some people have argued and Harris
argued it on the podcast or I wouldn't
say he's argued it.
He,
um,
I would say that he explained it in a
very interesting way.
It's compelling and you have to think
about it and take it into consideration
when you use terms like free will.
Well,
I would,
I mean,
so it gets down to this point of
decision,
right?
So when I look at like a lot of the
decisions that I make,
uh,
they're spontaneous and they're not,
I'm not sitting around thinking like,
how am I gonna turn my steering wheel at
this moment as I'm on the interstate?
What mild adjustments am I going to
make?
This is all just to kind of spontaneous
thing that seems to be part of
autopilot.
And I know a lot of people are running
on autopilot in most of what they do,
but I still don't think that it,
it,
it negates free will.
It's like a,
you could think of your life as a boat
and everyone's in a different shape boat
and the boat's been shaped by
experience.
Genetics,
gender.
Oh,
he's from my envision.
What kind of boat them?
What kind of vote of Mayan?
Yeah.
What kind of boat?
My boat has to,
has a fucking graying beard and one ball
brother.
He's tried to picture a fishing boat or
we in a cruise liner,
like let's just say it's a fucking for a
lot of people at ain't and cruise liner,
right?
For a lot of people.
It's a raft that's built of different
things that they've decided to grab out
of the infinite world of phenomena and
hammered together to some kind of
vessel,
which is their reality tunnel that
they're living in and they're navigating
this fucking raft.
And so sure,
some people,
they might have a boat that is a little
more cumbersome and a little more
difficult to navigate through the
neverending string of decisions that you
have to make if you exist inside of
time.
But still you can,
there's parts of that boat,
I guarantee it,
man.
There's parts of your boat that you can
revise.
You might not be able to change at all.
You're probably not gonna be able to
change your skin color.
You're not going to be able to change
your yet.
People are certainly changing the gender
of their fucking boats.
You know,
people are doing that right now.
And I think is technology continues to
advance.
Uh,
we're going to find that we're more like
crispr.
I think we're going to find we're more
and more able to like actually change
the structure of our boats according to
our desire,
but if you really analyze what's going
on in your life,
you will see that you are actively
making decisions from moment to moment
that are [inaudible] and who's making
the decision?
Well,
I don't know.
Well that's where it gets weird,
right?
If you want to say it's your gut biome,
if you want to say it's the ind of a
never ending series of decisions made by
never an extreme of,
wait a minute,
why does it have to be either or?
Isn't it all these things?
I mean that I think that's where the
argument gets really weird because I
think it's all these things.
Yeah,
it's life experiences and it's genetics
and it's choices and it's consciousness
and it's the willful expression of
positive ideas and forcing them on your
life and what is the motivation behind
that?
Is that your past?
Is it what you've learned?
Is it a fucking inspirational youtube
video you watched this afternoon?
Yeah.
Who Cares?
Whatever it is.
It's a bunch of shit.
It's a bunch of shit going on all over
the place.
And I think the idea of separating that
is akin to the idea of separating us
from all of the life that's on this
planet.
I think we've done a weird thing with
houses and clothes and cars.
We've done a weird thing where we're not
touching the world anymore.
We're not touching it with our feet.
We're not touching it with our skin.
We're allergic to a bunch of shit.
We can't get anything on us.
We can't go anywhere near a certain
animals.
If they touch your skin,
you get hives there.
There's a bunch of stuff that we've done
in separating ourselves from the natural
world.
It's left us really fucking confused,
and I think one of those confusions lies
in when we've created civilizations and
cities,
we've lost our contact,
our physical contact.
We don't have a physical contact.
The physical contact in nature is all
playing through the bottom of your
boots.
Uh,
you're breathing it in.
Still do occasionally touch it.
Yeah.
You occasionally brush up against a
tree,
but whatever influence these things have
through each other and this insane
network interwoven root systems and
mycelium and fungus and rotting leaves
and animals all around you and all that
you,
you get through a filter now,
all that stuff you get through your car
window,
all that stuff you get through your
clothes has share.
You don't,
you're not in contact with that stuff
anymore and by not being in contact with
it,
you forget that it has a message.
Like when you,
when you lay in the grass,
just lay in the grudge,
just go somewhere and lay in the grass.
It feels good.
It actually feels like the planet is
like,
like hug,
like you're hugging someone.
When you hug someone it feels good.
Sure.
It feels good to lay in a nice long as
no bugs.
Conti fucking hands went crawl up your
ass holes good to temporary lane if you
don't ask,
you don't lay down in a fire ant hive
and get fucked up by a bunch of bees or
bees by a bunch of bugs.
But I think that if you go into nature
on a daily basis,
like there was something that I,
I I read the other day that I tweeted
about them the some,
I forget who the,
what the university was,
but they were literally saying that
there is an argument that a certain
amount of nature is like a,
like a vitamin antidepressant.
Yeah.
Well like you get vitamin D from the
sun.
Yeah.
There's a certain amount of vitality.
There's a certain amount of positive
like life force that you get from being
in nature.
Makes sense man.
I mean,
I know that makes sense.
Whenever I go out,
I mean just like anything,
just like I got plants now that I have
to water.
It was another thing I was going to talk
to you about.
What I was going to ask you.
Do you think if these,
if these scientists are correct,
obviously they are about this
interconnection between plants and about
how they communicate with each other and
about how the even allocate resources to
those that are in need.
Is it fucked up to keep plants?
Is it fucked up to keep something that
you decide?
No,
you're going to leave in this box,
man.
You're going to live in this box right
here.
Ooh,
it's round.
Just keep looking for the outside.
Keeps spinning around.
You know you're not going to communicate
with anybody else because there isn't
anybody else.
It's just you.
It's just you lonely and fucked up
sitting in this pot.
Or can they communicate through the air?
Are they communicating through the air
and if it does it get through your
windows?
Man,
I got 7,000
things.
I got to feel bad about it.
The form of fucking house plants land
there.
But should you have plants in your house
in a pot?
Should they all be outside?
I mean,
if they're outside with their friends,
no problem.
Right?
If they're outside you,
you got a yard and you dig a hole and
you put your plants in there and you
water it and it's gross and it's a part
of the whole system.
That's like a dog with a yard.
Otherwise you're,
you got a German shepherd and you keep
him in a fucking little con tiny
kitchen.
Do you haven't got him pinned in there?
Do you ever do the thing where you start
thinking about how funny the concept of
inside and outside is?
You ever do that?
It's still funny cause it's like,
okay,
in my house I'm now inside.
Even though there's just like a layer of
wood around me,
I'm in some other place that's different
than the outside.
Even though you know you're,
you're really,
there is no such thing as 10 side.
I'll do you one better.
How about,
how about this?
How about the phrase the great outdoors?
All right.
What you mean reality?
You mean the earth itself?
Like it is odd to be an enthusiast of
the world itself.
We spend so much time in these
artificially created environments with
air conditioning and neon light.
Is it neon?
Depends.
Lcd Lights these days.
I think this is not lcd though.
Fluorescent,
right.
That's what I'm looking for.
Neon neons like cigars.
Yeah.
Um,
but these artificial environments that
we create,
we're in them way more than we are the
outside.
So when we're actually in the outdoors,
we can call ourselves,
I'm an outdoorsman.
What do you like to do?
I like to the great outdoors.
That's what I like,
Bro.
Sure.
I like to be in the great outdoors.
Yeah,
great outdoors is,
instead of saying the world nature,
I'm a nature enthusia.
I love nature in all its forms,
man,
including houses,
virtual reality,
not,
not just being in a fucking house,
Joe,
but being inside another universe inside
the house.
That is what I like and it's,
and also guess what?
Because a lot of anti vr people,
they're like,
whenever I got out,
y'all forget about outside.
No,
I go outside,
enjoy the sun,
enjoy my shitty little garden with a
speaking of fucking cruelty to plants,
God forbid you become one of my plans.
God forbid,
may you never be one of my plants,
but I still go out there and I try to
keep them alive.
But man,
Vr is such a beautiful thing because it
creates that same,
almost the same sense of like,
you know like when you go in a big space
and it feels good.
I don't know why,
but you aware it can be a shitty
warehouse,
but if it's big,
if you go into like an expansive plane,
they're like,
that's why it was good.
I put a is up from the Vatican,
there was in the Vatican last week or
two weeks ago and I went to St Peter's
basilica and I put a bunch of photos of
it on my instagram feed.
If you ever been to the Vatican,
not yet.
You got to go.
First of all,
it is trippy psychedelic.
There's a giant pine cone.
Okay.
They have this huge courtyard with a
huge pine cone,
which represents the pineal gland and
these two peacocks that represent
eternal life.
He cocks.
Apparently that's,
I took that photo.
Um,
the,
uh,
the guide was super psyched when I knew
at the pine cone,
met his eyes lit up and I say represents
the pineal gland,
right?
And he's like,
how do you know that?
And then we started talking about
Christianity and its potential routes in
psychedelic drugs and ancient Roman
culture and how,
you know,
like the John Marco Allegro book,
the sacred mushroom and the scroll where
he thought that what Christianity was
initially was a bunch of stories where
they hid the psychedelic rituals in
parables and stories to hit it from the
Romans because when they were being
conquered by the Romans,
they didn't them to know how magical the
mushrooms were and they were a
connection to God and that the pineal
gland,
like I forget the actual chemical
composition of DMT,
but or not the,
uh,
not dmt rather,
but mushrooms.
But what DMT is diamond,
the tryptamine is in some form.
That's what happens to psychedelic
mushrooms when you taken psilocybin.
I think it's,
I think it's like for Fox,
for a [inaudible],
and I know I'm butchering it and,
and dimethyl trip to me,
but it's some version of
dimethyltryptamine is produced when you
consume psilocybin mushrooms.
So these guys knew that,
they knew that.
And then it was a part of their art and
it represented that pineal gland is
giant fucking 15 foot tall pine cone
represented what they thought was the
seat of the soul.
That's why it's sitting there and this
fucking,
this gigantic tray being held up by
angels and Shit and whoever those saints
see to this sill.
See that's the fucking vr goggles for
the soul.
That's what that is.
That's the way we peer into this
dimension.
Look at the St Peter's Basilica.
These photos,
this is from [inaudible] that they built
in the 16 hundreds with no,
they had no computers.
They had no power tools.
They had no,
and there's photos on my instagram.
There it is.
So cool dude.
You're seeing it right now in a picture
and I'm telling you it doesn't do it
justice.
This thing's insane.
It took hundreds of years to fully
complete and the size of it and the
scale of it,
it's mine.
But there's one photo that I put,
we can see the actual people in the
background look at the size of that
fucking place.
And that is a small sliver of how big
the places,
I'm telling you,
it's not doing it any justice.
It's perfect.
The artwork is staggering.
I mean,
staff,
everybody talks about the Sistine
Chapel,
the sistine chapels.
Pretty fucking beautiful.
I mean,
without a doubt,
it's a modern,
I mean,
not a modern,
uh,
an amazing work of art.
But it ain't shit compared to St Peter's
Basilica.
Look at that.
It's the all seeing eye to this is,
that's the,
that's the sunroof.
That's the,
that's an eyeball.
Whatever it is.
I don't know if you now look at that,
that's definitely an eyeball.
A bunch of people in the eyeball and
there are angels.
There's angels got stuck in God's
eyeball.
Couldn't that just be alive?
It was impossible.
It's just whole light.
No,
Joe,
look right underneath that.
I see that pyramid right under the eye,
dude.
How the fuck did they even climb up
there?
That,
that's a,
um,
a photo of Hercules,
that last one that's a gigantic bronze
Hercules that they buried in the second
century.
They build it in the second century d
but it got hit by lightning twice.
And they went,
this thing is fucking Honda head.
So they buried him.
They buried it underground.
They didn't find it until 1864 wow.
He's an amazing dude that the Vatican is
a mind.
Fuck.
That floor is 1700 years old and you
walk on it.
Everybody walks on it.
Thousands of people a day walk on a 1700
year
old mosaic floor.
Pretty cool man.
That's where they say they've got all
these like hidden manuscripts and shit
that no one's ever going to see.
That's what you would initially
gravitate to.
Wouldn't you?
Secrets the secrets.
Are you kidding?
The Vatican's filled with secrets,
man.
A little boy's secrets.
David notches that lots of other shit
too,
man.
They've been gathering information.
I mean,
think about it.
It's like they,
they've controlled so many world leaders
who have done confessions and you think
that the Vatican doesn't like when a
world leader gives a confession,
doesn't write that shit down,
put it in the fucking lie.
They probably have confessions of some
of the greatest kings.
They knew everything.
Man.
It's the priest class freaking me out.
It's true.
You're freaking me out.
Anyway.
I hope I am.
I man,
that's a fucking Vatican.
Think about what that is.
That there are a country.
Yeah,
it's a country.
It's a small country.
It's a hundred acre country.
Every time a Catholic puts money in a
bowl,
it a little bit of that money makes it
to that fucking place.
That's the nexus point of dough for one
of the world's one branch of the world's
main religions.
That's a fucking cool.
That's just all the money.
People who are like just at the end of
their fucking rope,
people who have like $3,000
left in their bank account,
but they were like,
you know what?
I'm going to give this to the church
because God will bless me.
They give that money to the church and
that money goes straight to build an a
fucking shitty lightening catching
statue.
That's what all the money of people who
desperately needed it for actual things
has gotten sucked to the Vatican where
it's used to build gold thrones that the
pope sits on and talks about the
importance of charity.
It's hilarious.
Well,
he did.
The new guy doesn't do it anymore.
The new guy doesn't do sit on the
throne.
Now here's a real chair.
He could archive six the most intriguing
documents and church history.
Oh my God.
Documents from the Galileo heresy trial.
I'd throw that one out of,
I was the Catholic Church.
Let's forget about that.
Forget about that.
She told me you wouldn't want to read
that when they were telling him,
hey dude,
you're wrong.
The Earth is the center of the fucking
universe now.
Either you want to stay in that attic
for the rest of your life like that.
A serial killer lady and with that lady,
serial killer lady,
what was her name?
But Oh,
killed all the young women.
Henry this seventh asking for a divorce,
an anoma.
A king has to ask your permission.
You've become so powerful.
Kings are like,
can I please break up with my
girlfriend?
That's Henry the eighth he was the one
that chopped their heads off,
right?
Yeah.
That's the ultimate enjoyment.
That's when he got sick of sending
letters.
They still use v I.
We had a guess.
You know,
you said the seventh and I said the
eighth I had account those little lines.
That reminds me,
I'm sure you've already talked about
this in the podcast and it's stupid.
So go ahead and call me stupid if,
and I'm sorry if you already told
pre-claim things you know about the
baron,
you know the berenstain bears?
Yes.
Fuck yeah.
We've probably got a million vice had a
whole lot
article about it.
I didn't,
I didn't really remember it,
so it wasn't that much of a revelation
to me.
I don't think I read that when I was a
kid.
I was more of a Dr Seuss turned kid.
I didn't understand that it was,
everybody thought it was steam,
but it was what I thought.
And then,
yeah,
I definitely thought that.
But the idea that some people remember
that Nelson Mandela died in prison and
some people think he got out.
That's the trippiest idea.
Have you ever,
you know,
Queen Song,
we are the champions.
Everybody think it ends with of the
world,
but it doesn't,
it just ends and everybody tries to sing
of the world,
but it doesn't end that way.
Like there's a funny thing that this guy
does on youtube where he gets in a car
and he drives people around,
they lip sync,
they sing along like Karaoke.
Rather they sing along to songs and
they're singing along to the queen song.
We are the champions and it gets to the
end and it's George.
Um,
what the fuck's his name?
The actor,
George Clooney and Julia Roberts and uh,
someone else.
I forget who the other person is and
they're singing along and it gets to the
end and they all want to say of the
world and it doesn't say that.
And they're like,
what the fuck?
And they're all confused.
And I thought it did too.
Everybody does.
It seems like there's a,
a line that we all collectively decided
was missing from that song.
It's a collective fuck up of memory
time,
traveler proof.
I wish we could play it,
but we can't play it.
They'll yank is off youtube,
but find the video.
See just to see if you can find the
video so we could tell people what video
to watch because it's hilarious watching
George Clooney get to the end and want
to say,
Oh man,
what a bad motherfucker Freddie Mercury
was.
You ever listened to queen every now and
again throwing some queen.
It's insane.
Jesus.
He was good.
He was so Bohemian.
Rhapsody would play that.
And you're like,
what?
Like what a,
what an amazing piece of expression.
He seems like he was one of the most
disciplined people when it came to his
work.
Like it's,
he seems like somebody who is constantly
working on his voice.
Just a workaholic maybe.
Maybe for sure.
Unbelievably talented and [inaudible]
and had an incredible knack for
expressing himself.
How she wasn't even at some NPR
interview with,
uh,
I can't remember.
She's a famous broadway singer and she's
talking about what she does every day
and it's crazy.
Oh to sing on Broadway.
Oh God.
She's like,
it's like three hours of physical
exercise a day mixed in with an hour of
meditation.
Makes them with vocal exercises.
So it's like every single day she's
doing like an eight hour prep for this
shit that she's doing.
It's amazing when you
hear about people who are at that
discipline.
Yeah.
That's not good for us.
We can't do that shit,
dude.
What is this is them,
they get to the end.
Oh,
it's Gwen Steffani was the other one.
We owe the chain the chain.
Okay.
We can't play it because it's not the
music.
It's just dumb singing.
But we can't do it because it's their
video yet.
It's James Corden show.
Who's James Corden?
The late,
late show he took over for Craig
Ferguson this past year,
I think.
Here they go.
They get to the part at the end.
No,
we don't have to see this.
I'm scared.
Yeah,
we're going to get yanked off youtube.
Uh,
there was a big thing that I tweeted
today where some guy was talking about
his audio book being on Youtube.
Oh yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah.
And people are,
this guy said that he sold 50,000
audio books,
but there was like 19,000
views or something like that on Youtube.
And he was like,
what in the fuck?
Like that's a giant chunk of the people
that have listened to my book,
pirated it,
you know,
and he's like,
Hey,
I get,
this is how I make a living when I get
paid from this stuff.
It's interesting because you know,
obviously youtube has them up and they,
you know,
somehow or another,
someone puts it up there and they didn't
get it down without a request.
Like Yep,
there's an algorithm that finds it.
You have to find it.
So like it's totally possible.
I'm sure a lot of your bits or up there
somewhere where someone's put them up
and they put them up on the channel.
You just don't,
you don't know.
You mean from the podcast,
from podcasts,
from staff,
from,
but imagine if you had a book and you
made all your money.
If you're an author or you make all your
money off the audio book or a big
percentage at least,
can't they just claim 100 right?
Claim wonders,
get it off.
But those 19,000
views he doesn't get,
those are gone.
You know,
like how many of those 19,000
views would have translated into selling
an audio book?
Is that real
question is the real question,
if any.
And here's the real question for
standups,
right?
The always the question is when you are
bits,
make it on youtube,
like say if you do a comedy central
special in particular,
right.
And then your bits make it on youtube,
the more people pirate your stuff.
I don't know if you'd call it pirating,
but more they take it and they put it on
Youtube,
the more people are going to see you,
the more people are going to come to see
you,
the more it's going to be worth it to
you to do another comedy central spot.
Right?
Right.
So it becomes different for us because
we,
we kind of exist for the live shows,
like the live shows,
the big,
big part of what we do.
Right?
Yeah.
And anything that'll get more people to
go to the live shows,
it's like a better thing,
right?
Yeah.
How it thinks how now for an author,
for that guy,
he's,
he feels like he got fucked.
You know,
well I think,
wasn't he saying that like Youtube,
like culpable here,
like youtube is making money off of the
thing in some indirect way that and
acting like they're not like it is like
who's the person who is because the
person who uploaded it,
are they generating money from the thing
or are they,
did they just upload it because love it?
That's a good
question.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that,
that's where it gets weird is it?
And,
and I think in the article he was saying
how,
you know,
with a lot of music now,
thank God when you upload it on your
Youtube Stream,
they just get a,
they just get the profits from whatever
you're advertising.
And that's way better than what it used
to be.
They just need,
they need to upgrade the system.
So this guy gets the same deal he has
with audible anytime somebody listens to
the book.
Yeah,
I mean,
I definitely think that he deserves that
for sure.
But here's my weirdness about all this.
You know,
we were talking about language and the
limitations of language and the
eventuality of a virtual reality.
And I wonder how we're going to digest
data and information in a virtual world.
Like if people decide like what if you
decide that you want to read books in a
virtual world,
this is how you want to read books.
The way you want to read books is what
your feet up on the couch in your
mansion and your virtual world.
All these girls around you like finger
banging themselves with a high heels on
and Queens,
fat bottom girls.
You make a rock in the world,
go round,
plays in the background share,
and you get to sit down and read books
in a virtual world.
What happens then?
Like what?
What happens when you're watching movies
in a virtual world?
That's probably,
that'd be stupid.
Famous streaming.
I think the movies would be,
they would exist.
I think movies in a virtual world,
they're definitely coming,
right?
And they're going to,
you're going to exist in the world like
you're not gonna sit down and watch a
movie.
Oh No.
They have a great theory theaters in Vr
now you can sit down,
put on a movie and watch it on.
Unlike a massive screen in vr there.
I went to,
don't you think,
why do they do that as their limitations
in the medium where they can't have it?
Uh,
the movie play out in front of you.
Like if you went to see jaws,
oh,
that's dope.
It's kind of Nice to watch a movie
floating in space.
I don't mind that the virtue of you,
there's an app called virtual desktop
where you like,
you put on your vr goggles and suddenly
your desktop is wrapped around you,
a giant screen,
giant screen wrapped around you that you
then can like pull up any kind of movie
you might want to watch.
And so you just like can sit in there
and why.
And if you look down,
you see space.
Yeah,
that's it.
Virtual desktop that.
Now the problem with Vr,
when you look at that,
the problem with Vr,
like people looking at it on the
Internet is it you cannot convey how
fucking cool it looks from looking at it
that way.
Like it is suddenly there's this massive
thing in front of you.
The space look real,
what the space looked real.
Um,
it,
it looks real enough pretty.
I wouldn't say that.
I mean I wouldn't say realistic.
I think there are probably some,
there's got to be by now some three 60
videos that are actually from the,
from Hubble,
but it looks good enough where you're
like,
this is fucking incredible.
Well what's the benefit
of like they're just watching you play a
video game.
What's the benefit and playing a video
game on a screen in a virtual world
instead of playing the video game in the
virtual world?
Well I think,
but honestly in that case,
I don't know.
Like I've,
I started a game up in there and he's
like,
fuck this.
You see what I'm saying here?
Because like he's clicking and menus and
stuff.
He's using it like a computer.
Yeah.
I think it's a,
I don't know if the benefit is the right
thing to look for there.
It's just,
it's just bad ass to like suddenly be
completely immersed in a new environment
doing like whatever the work is that you
want to do that with virtual desktop.
I just use it to watch documentaries
about bleeding.
But what I'm thinking is like,
would you rather like,
okay,
like they're perfect example,
you're looking at a screen,
right?
Clearly a floating screen,
if you watch jaws and that floating
screen,
that would not be as good as if you were
sitting in your living room when you're
looking down.
You were on the boat with Roy Scheider.
Well he was like,
we're gonna need a bigger boat.
Oh,
you mean like if there was like a vr
jaws?
Yes.
Oh yeah,
that'd be fucking cool.
It just doesn't exist yet.
Right.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like that's going to happen.
Right?
Of course.
Yeah,
that'll definitely happen for sure.
No question.
And when they do things like that,
like will you be able to enjoy other
things in that world?
Like will you be able to go into that
world?
Like here we're in the Swiss Alps,
where the fuck we are in a fake world?
Would you be able to go to this place
and put on a,
an a,
a podcast?
Like would you be able to like look down
at your phone,
find the Duncan trussell family hour and
start streaming it live on your phone
while you're skiing down the side of
this virtual hill,
which you're building.
You can already,
you can already do that.
You could already do that.
Yeah.
Look,
I mean look man,
this is like rick and Morty is video
game is in Vr is accepting that you're
in vr and,
and they're,
they're,
yeah,
there's like there's a,
there's all kinds of shit you could do
in there.
Like for example,
man,
there's a,
um,
in one of these games called fantastic
contraption,
which is one of the most site dude show,
split reality,
fantastic contraption.
If you looked at this where people have
managed to put up a green screen so that
can interpolate the two videos.
So it looks like you're actually in the
game.
That's the clothes show.
That fantastic contraption is this.
Everything in there is fucking
psychedelic.
But check this out.
When you see people in the,
in the reality itself,
yeah.
There you go.
Whoa.
Watch what he does.
So this guy's walking around.
This is what he's seeing.
So what we're looking at and what are we
seeing?
Does this gonna what?
We're going to kicked off use youtube
for this.
You don't need the daughter?
Yeah.
Don't know audio please.
I'm worried.
But then so this guy's moving around and
while he's moving around,
he's doing a bunch of stuff.
He's got a bunch of front of house one
though.
For sure.
There's like,
well it takes to explain to the people
that are listening what we're saying.
Oh yeah,
you're,
you're just seeing like in fantastic
contraption.
What is that?
What is fantastic contraption?
You're in this like weird putting green
and you have to build amazing devices to
um,
Eh,
the white.
Unfortunately these videos,
you're not seeing the guy actually form
the shit.
Like watch this.
What am I watching Dunkin?
We started,
people are listening.
Watch this.
Oh,
sorry.
You're seeing,
look at this.
Look at this.
You have to stretch out these like tubes
to build this weird device that you like
then automates itself to try to,
I mean,
honest to God,
talking about it,
you feel like a fucking,
you're listening to an eight year old
talk about a drawing
they made.
Like what?
What are you talking about?
It's impossible to convey.
It's a game and it's a game where this
guy is moving,
he's got devices in his hand and then
devices move things in the virtual
world.
He's holding on to these two like a
controllers.
But this is not a good,
if you look up crazy matter,
it's pretty fucking he fucking cool.
Yeah.
You'll see it on Friday.
I'll show you.
I've got us and what we need to talk
about his porn.
What's that like Duncan?
What's it like in this world?
What's it like?
So,
um,
I mean it's like I'll tell you something
even better than porn man.
Oh.
Um,
here's what's really cool about vr that
I don't think a lot of people have
caught onto.
Maybe a few of them have.
Cause the porn of course is amazing.
It is an,
it is.
If anything is going to drive vr and I
hope everything drives Vr,
it's going to be the fucking porn
because the porn that is shot for Vr is
very,
very close to like experiencing having
sex with someone,
obviously minus the body.
Right?
There's nobody there.
But it's amazing and it's going to cause
a lot of great and hilarious problems.
And I'm excited to hear the outrage that
comes from the world when people start
realizing that every single person on
earth now has access not just to in a
voyeuristic way witnessing,
uh,
Ooh,
that,
that I'm telling you man,
that is,
that's,
that's what those girls acids and insane
and so she's right in front of you.
But this is,
they're not doing a good job with us
cause it's got to
eyeball.
That's just how it,
yeah,
you,
you have to use virtual desktop to bring
those two things together.
Like the porn that you download is
broken up in stereoscopic.
So the vr goggles bring it together
to kill you.
You have to get specific programs that
are designed for this,
right?
Yeah.
Like a,
yeah,
just google search.
Reddit,
how not to watch vr porn.
So these guys that are watching it,
like we're watching this guy who's
sitting on his bed and like he's looks
like he's doing everything to keep from
coming in his pants.
He's laugh like I don't ever watch porn
like that.
There's like sheer joy and him watching
that porn,
like what you're talking about is
something that's very different than
watching a two dimensional screen.
It's,
it's as different as sax and watching a
two dimensional screen except there's no
body there.
I mean you are in,
you look or you can look around,
you can like,
you know,
like for example,
let's say there was a,
and by the way,
I'm not doing this shit.
A friend of mine watches it,
but let's say,
let's say that there was a,
um,
uh,
in a,
in a vr porn experience,
there's a girl who's giving you a blow
job while another girl is shoving your
pussy in your face.
You can actually look up and see your
pussy,
not our pussy.
You can look around her pussy and see,
see your face looking down at you just
like it was really happening.
So that's Vr porn.
That's what it's alignment.
You can look at her pussy and then you
can go back to sure the girls sucking
your Dick.
You give,
you have,
you can move anywhere.
You could stare at her feet if you're a
Weirdo or not.
If you just were a fan of feet either
way,
either way.
Either way.
It's,
it's,
and it's still a game changer.
It's a game changer,
man.
It's a game changer and it's one of the
many freedoms the virtual reality's
offering people.
It's like you were saying,
who wants to like even just watching a
movie in two D in your virtual reality
room,
it's pretty awesome.
Maybe you don't have the greatest
apartment,
right?
But you put on vr goggles and suddenly
your apartment has transformed into a,
into a massive,
beautiful space in the htc vive.
It comes with like Vr home and there's
two different versions.
But when you go into this space,
you feel that same sense of
expansiveness that you get from being in
a big space,
right?
Like it's,
your body's still like,
feels like it's,
you know,
you're in a,
you still feel that weird sense of
freedom that you feel when you're in a
big space and you're not there.
It's beautiful,
man.
It's like one of the most liberating,
incredible technologies.
I think that a lot,
some people are giving it a little bit
of a hard time right now because they
see the game from Youtube and they think
those graphics look like Shit.
But let me tell you,
man,
do minecraft in Vr.
Like I just,
I did minecraft and Vr.
I play my graft vr regularly now,
but you do minecraft and vr and when
suddenly you're perched on the edge of a
cliff looking down on some hyper colored
underground river,
your body initially reacts in the same
way or reacts to being at the edge of a
real cliff.
Your balance gets weird.
You're like,
fuck,
fuck.
It's that real.
That's the vive.
The htc vive is in fucking saying,
Jesus,
I can't wait to show you man.
It's like,
it just works.
It doesn't,
it doesn't mess up.
Like anytime I want to now I can go.
I've made a room in my house where now I
can just put on these goggles and I'm
instantly in.
Oh fucking there's a game called a hover
junkers,
which is so fun.
So you,
um,
you,
you could,
you could probably pull it up.
You ride around like it knows how big
the space is that what's called your
play space.
They knows how big it is.
So you're riding in a craft in this
place,
space shooting weapons at people flying
around in these other things.
Yeah.
It's so you could like,
you could all go in your garage and you
could,
uh,
the garage would become the environment
where you're playing your game.
Oh yeah.
Man,
you're not in your garage anymore.
You're flying around in that fucking
thing shooting at people,
which means you actually have to be good
at shooting.
Like you have to be able to aim,
this isn't like pressing buttons.
Like,
you need to know how to fire at least at
some Saudi,
what are you holding?
Are you holding a fake gun?
Now you're holding these controllers
that feel exactly like a fucking,
they feel very close to a gun and it's
got haptic technology.
So when you're shooting it's vibrating.
I wonder if this would actually teach
you how to shoot better.
They have,
they have a great archery program.
Is,
is it making your art tree better?
Uh,
it's making me not do archery cause I
just do it.
It's way easier.
Are you good at it?
Are you good at this archery?
Yeah,
it me doing real archery jet definitely
translated into me playing look up the,
I'm sorry to keep asking.
You look up stuff.
Jamie.
Look up,
uh,
archery.
The lab vr.
This is one of my favorite archery
programs.
They also have a vr boxing,
which I haven't tried yet,
but which I'm excited about because that
seems like you could really train people
to learn how to box.
Let's see.
I'm s I don't know if this is,
yeah,
that's,
that's a different archery program than
the one that look up the lab.
Okay.
Ah,
fuck.
It's,
it's valve look up valve archery.
Vr.
Now there is,
yeah.
This one's a really fucking fun man.
Okay.
Yeah.
This one is fucking cool.
You just shoot it.
These little guys who are trying to
infiltrate your,
oh,
so you're shooting at things.
Yeah.
And it's,
so it's a game.
Yeah.
My God.
And you are you pulling a bow back?
Like what are you doing in your hand?
So you have two controllers,
you're pulling them back.
There's haptics.
So it vibrates according to this,
the tension of the bow string.
And then when you want an Arrow,
you're reaching behind your back and
pulling it from behind your back.
Dot is nuts,
man.
Yeah,
it's so fun.
I wonder if it actually could help your
archery skill for sure.
The only problem is it's really weird
because you get used to like,
um,
it's different because you use a
compound bow,
but you know,
you get,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of same.
You get used to like I have a place on
my cheek where I put my point,
the anchor point changes cause the
goggles right up here.
So you have to get a new anchor point.
But it's still pretty fucking fun.
I mean how often you get to shoot at
things in and like an archery range like
this?
Yeah,
this is wild.
And I wonder,
that means it should
definitely be able to do something like
this for a compound bows.
That's say go deer hunting with it.
There's another archery program that you
can get on steam that it looks pretty
cool.
Uh,
I can't remember the name of it though,
but it looks a little bit more,
I guess,
realistic.
Well,
they have an archery program.
See if you could find this archery
program where you shoot at a virtual
screen,
you actually shoot a real bow at,
uh,
these images on a screen.
And this,
uh,
like you,
you go to like in front of like a giant
movie theater type thing and you stand
in front of this thing and these animals
walked by.
I,
that's cool.
And they run from you and they hide and
you got to sneak up on them and shoot
arrows at them.
I mean I'm sure this will be translated
into vr and I'll tell you joe,
if I was,
if I were you man,
I would be developing shit for Vr.
Right?
Developing.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
It's not a developer.
I would,
I,
there's so many ideas that you will have
when you try these goggles on where
you're going to be like this,
this needs to exist in the world,
get this shit developed man.
Because it's gonna like there's so many
things that once you experience it where
like Oh someone needs to build this.
Someone like for example a fucking
boxing,
Jamie's nodding in the,
in the one hour I think I got a
demonstration of it.
I was just sitting there asking the guy,
so what about when someone gets a hold
of this and they start thinking about
doing this thing and what about when
rock star gets it and then they start
thinking about making grand theft auto
this way.
It's like,
yes Zach,
your brain just steak.
Well fallout is coming for the vive,
which is going to be pretty fucking
cool.
But dude from the,
and they have like a a boxing program
that looks like it's still in
development but a fucking real boxing
program because it tracks the
controllers perfectly in real time.
So you could actually learn how to box.
Yes.
Someone needs to build a real fun,
not only learn how to box,
but you could train with the great
boxers like you could throw kicks to,
well you'd have to have something on
your foot.
You'd have to have another edition.
It was like that could be done boots
right.
Easily man.
Easily kind of sneakers that you get a
great fucking workout too.
Oh I'm sure.
I remember when people were doing dance
dance revolution.
They lost tons of weight.
Yeah,
there was a huge thing a lot of guys
lost and gals lost a ton of weight off
that dance dance revolution again cause
it was so fun to do.
Well,
that's what's funny about Vr is that
right now when people think of a video
Gamer,
they don't,
you're not going to hear someone say,
Oh,
they are lean and Tan and they like her
deck.
They have such dexterity.
But now when you think of someone who's
great at Vr,
they're going to,
you gotta be in fucking Shit.
There's the boxing program.
I'm going to download it.
The creators of this,
or seem like they're super cool.
I think I could get a good workout with
this.
They have vr pool.
How good.
I don't want that pools for real.
But see,
the thing about this is this is
something that you could do on your own
and get a workout in.
What I,
what I find interesting about this too
is you could tune a dude up and you
don't feel bad about it right now.
What you need to do eventually is
they're going to
have something that looks like this,
but it's a robot.
Like both things.
Like you have a thing that you can
actually hit.
Well now you could just,
you could already,
I'm sure there's a way that you could
hang a bag and um,
cause like,
okay,
so when I,
um,
what I'm talking about southern the hits
back,
well yeah,
that's that,
that's going to be something that
phrase,
it doesn't have to have a lot of power.
They could have like a really mushy arm
and it knows how to move the way,
the way you move,
like
Zach's a throwing punches at you.
So if it hits you,
it's not hurting you.
You know what that could be,
man.
It can be like a haptic face mask that
registers the punch and vibrates so that
you could feel it,
you know,
and wherever it hits you,
it could
be,
but it also could be like some sort of a
robot that has inflatable arms and the
inflatable arms move with the program.
So as you're looking at Apollo creed in
front of you,
when he snaps his jab out at you pop,
he's,
he's throwing this like spongy,
almost like a inflatable raft balloon
arm.
You know,
like when you're little kids inflatable
balloon toys.
Yeah,
I like that.
Like,
he's not going to hurt you at all.
It's just going to touch your face.
Be fucking incredible.
And what's in,
what you're going to see,
man,
is people are going to get really good
at this shit.
Like if you're good at shooting and vr
minus like the heft of the gun and the
real kick of whatever gun in the real
world.
Are you using your,
it's,
it's going to translate.
We are tomorrow and just float in
Pasadena.
Um,
Zach,
Larry and I are testing out,
I think for the first time Vr in a float
tank and Zach leary,
Timothy leary's son Timothy leary.
Are you up to Duncan trussell Oh,
you dropping out and tuning in and we're
trying to induce the observer effect.
We've got this awesome guy,
Dustin,
who's,
uh,
helped us,
um,
help helped us build a floating in space
program.
So the idea is,
can you like induced the effect
astronauts report when they're floating
in space looking down on earth.
If you,
if you put someone in the zero g or the
Semis Erg of a float tank and give them
the impression that they're staring down
on planet earth and we've got this
genius designer is,
I haven't looked at it yet.
You are freaking me the fuck out right
now.
Well let's hope it works man.
I mean this is something that makes
sense to me in my world.
The world of the float.
Yeah man.
We'll know like something like that,
like adding floating to it.
You know,
crash was trying to do something similar
a long time ago.
He was developing programs.
He developed a screen crash from the
float lab,
I should say.
He's the one of the big innovators have
a floating tanks in this country.
He developed a screen that had one of
the lowest emissions of light possible
so that when you be lying down in this
tank,
complete darkness,
you would look up at the screen and the
amount of light came out.
It was so minuscule that allowed you to
see clearly the images but didn't show a
the line of
a screen.
So you were never removed from this idea
that you're floating through the
universe,
but in front of you while these things
are playing out and he had this idea
that you would learn things easier that
way.
Like you could watch like a golf
documentary or a golf,
a instructional rather,
and you could learn like how to swing a
golf club properly because you would be
seeing it through a first person
perspective.
Well,
um,
Zach's dad had this idea,
I think it's called the Timothy leary.
Tim leary probably say who his dad was.
Tim Timothy.
Timothy leary had this idea of the eight
circuits of clothes.
Zach's dad.
Yeah,
maybe sweetie.
Well,
I mean any w and he was a fucking
sweetie.
Tim leary was like Tim Timothy leary
was,
he was,
I put them on the same level as Galileo.
He was an incredibly brilliant human
being and a lot of his ideas got lost
and is like he,
he gets called an lsd propagandist,
but there's a lot of other shit he was
coming up with.
And I'm one of those was this model,
I think it's the eight circuits of
consciousness.
So the idea is that humans are meant to
migrate into space.
And that in the same way like different
creatures,
when they enter into new habitats,
they actually change a little bit.
There's,
or in other words,
like you take a a sea turtle,
he's laid eggs in the sand and the first
time a little baby sea turtle climbs out
of the egg and burroughs out of the
sand.
It's a land creature until it hits
water.
And then all of a sudden all of this
other instinctual shit kicks in and it
learns how to be a sea turtle.
More than likely it gets eaten.
Not a lot of them make it,
but the ones that survive become sea
turtles.
Right?
So,
so the idea is that humans are meant for
interstellar,
for,
for tr,
for travel in space,
and that if we go into zero g then over
what could potentially happen,
uh,
our changes in our psyche and maybe even
in our genetic makeup,
like maybe if we go into space long
enough,
we'll start transforming into some new
creature that we were meant to be.
So
was it ed Mitchell that was talking
about the experience of being in space
that he would like to take everybody up
there and that you would realize how
ridiculous boundaries are and how
ridiculous wars are.
If you could see the earth as a whole,
the way he saw it
at Mitchell,
is he still alive?
I believe he is Mitchell or trying to do
it for your brother and mental is not
alive.
No,
he died.
Ah,
well what was a,
he was an interesting guy.
He was an interesting one because he was
really into Ufos,
especially before he died.
He was one of the more compelling cases
of someone who went into space and came
back with a profound belief in Ufos.
But you know,
it's always hard.
You don't know the guy.
I don't know the guy.
I don't know what his motivation was.
I hope he was being honest.
But there's a lot of money and you lfos
if you're a fucking astronaut and you
want to cash in,
that's the best way.
I'm not,
I'm not saying
that he would do it.
I'm not saying that,
but the cynic in me has to always go,
well,
how well do they take care of their
astronauts?
I mean,
how well did they get?
I'll tell you what,
man,
if you can tap into some of that sweet,
sweet ufo money,
it's a lot of money in them.
UFO books,
little green men.
I want little green bits of paper,
motherfucker.
I mean,
it's not like Hillary Clinton speaking
fees.
But if you can get a former us
astronauts who went to the moon to sit
down and talk to you about the little
green men that he might have seen or the
idea that they might exist.
Well,
you know what,
man,
you,
you know,
there are nefarious people in this world
and I don't know if fucking had Mitchell
I saw Ufo is or not.
It wouldn't surprise me that there are,
uh,
other creatures that you run into up
there that for whatever reason,
you're not supposed to announce,
I don't know man.
Totally possible.
Look,
if we could send a robot to Mars,
there's totally possible that
something's up there.
It's totally possible that something is
around the earth.
All the time.
We just don't get a chance to see it.
I mean,
this is what Terence Mckenna always
talked about.
It's like we spent all this money on
these telescopes when for however you
don't even,
most people won't even sell you DMT.
They give it to you.
But like when you know,
just like however much it costs for
whatever the device you use to inhale
the DMT or however much the it cost you
to get down to wherever the IOWASCA
Sharman was or whatever it is,
you're going to encounter things that
seem to have a personality that is not
your personality and that they don't
have a normal human body.
And you know,
I was just reading Alistair Crawley last
night and he's talking about,
we use the term angel,
not because we're saying there's some
angel out there,
but it's more convenient than saying
here is a representation of the higher
form of human intelligence that is come
and in the form of an archetype that our
brains translate as an angel.
It's just easier to call it an angel for
the sake of just pragmatism because you
want to achieve some goal.
Just call it a fucking angel.
We used to call aliens angels.
That's what we used to call him.
The idea of a person with no possible
way of measuring what something is,
even if,
whether you have an experience or not,
I have to take your word for it.
I'm assuming you had an experience,
you said it was an angel.
The idea of putting a label on that,
a definitive label like,
oh,
I definitely met an angel.
Right?
How the fuck do you know what an angel
is?
Right?
How do you know it was an alien?
It was definitely an alien.
You sure it wasn't an angel?
How do you know?
You don't know.
You're guessing,
right?
You don't know what an angel is or an
alien isn't.
As a matter of fact,
you shouldn't be able to say those words
because you don't even know what the
fuck they mean either one of those
words.
You're just saying nonsense.
And for you to be like super definitive
about it.
Like you're,
you're,
you're definitely sure that it was an
angel or you're definitely sure that it
was an alien.
You're crazy.
You don't even know what you saw.
Well,
you don't have anything that you can
bring back.
There's no physical matter where you
brought to a scientist and bunch of peer
reviewed scientists from all over the
world studied it and determined that
this was actually alien tissue.
Now there's none of that.
So no matter what it is,
the labels ridiculous,
right?
And they get caught up in the label is,
is of to waste your time unless you're
using the label is a,
is something to expedite your ability to
recontact that thing in which case
labels are fantastic.
But if you're using the label to say,
Oh yes,
this is definitely an angel,
and then you're like getting in the most
insanely stupid arguments over that,
then it's a bit of a waste of time.
But if you have an experience,
for example,
I don't know,
you smoked dmt and you come into contact
with it's self transforming machine
elves that as Terence Mckenna,
hyperspace and hyperspace,
right?
So is that really what those things call
themselves?
If they could?
No,
of course not.
But as a tool or a means of trying to in
some way bring the uh,
transcendent into this dimension,
then language is a,
is a necessity.
You have no choice.
Well not just that,
but in Mckenna's case it was part of the
grand theater of being someone who is a,
a dmt evangelist.
Right?
I mean,
part of his,
his art of what he is is a performer.
Like I'm a big fan of his lectures.
I enjoyed watching him talk,
I enjoyed listening to him talk,
but part of what he was doing was very
entertaining.
He had this oddly soothing voice,
this brilliant vocabulary.
And one of the things he did in one of
these interviews that he did a,
he was a,
not interviews rather a,
he's do q and a's with the audience
would ask them questions about
psychedelic drugs and things along those
lines.
Um,
someone was asking him something and he
said,
you know,
they were like,
well,
what can you do and how do you
differentiate and how do you keep from
being arrested?
He goes,
well,
no,
I use big words,
you know,
and he's a,
he's a legitimate scholar.
And he's like,
if you come up with slogans like dropout
tune in,
like,
yeah,
he goes,
that's when they come and he goes,
I keep it low key.
I have these small meetings,
they rarely get over a thousand people.
And uh,
I use a lot of really big words and a,
I use the,
the richest vocabulary for description
that I can muster up.
Right.
It was interesting because like you
listen to,
and he's obviously like incredibly well
educated,
right?
And incredibly knowledgeable about the
actual physical compounds of all these
different psychedelics and their
mechanisms for interaction and the
monoamine oxidase inhibitors.
And all these different things that he's
saying that are like,
it causes like people who are not that
smart to go,
oh,
okay.
We let them
go.
Let him keep talking to her.
I hope to God they don't care that much
about people talking about that stuff,
man.
It and I,
it's not,
they,
I don't know.
I don't
believe there's a day.
Don't,
there's a few people that are they,
but those few people that are,
they the,
they're bankers and their industrialists
and there the military industrial that
people that are earning money off of
wars and controlling resources,
if you really think that they are
somehow or another actively trying to
uh,
and capture or capture people that are
talking openly about psychedelics,
they don't have time for that shit
either way,
if I really don't think they do.
Have you seen that video of Tim leary in
front of the Senate and a hearing
that was like 1960?
What was it?
I want to say it was like,
I don't know,
the year.
It's one of the funniest fucking things
ever.
This is our cause he's a madman and he's
in front of these like just hardcore
politicians talking about the LSD
experience.
Do you think will get pulled off youtube
if we play that?
I think that's public fucking don't we
own that?
Cause it's a s
it should,
it should be the,
it'd be a historical thing.
Well there's a,
there's a amount of time things have to
right.
I don't know.
Public domain,
if it's like video,
I guess it depends on who filmed that.
Like if it's as a TV station filmed it,
it's there.
It's,
but if it's like the government filming
it,
I don't know for sure.
Like,
I don't know.
You've seen video of it.
Yeah,
there's definitely video footage and
it's on it.
There's a documentary right now called
dying to know,
which is an amazing movie about,
um,
Ron doss and Timothy leary's friendship
and it sort of follows the scope of
their lives together.
It's amazing.
It's fucking,
well,
well shot,
but it's real,
but it's,
it's on there.
I'm surprised it's not.
Um,
not anyways,
before I forget this again,
this is another thing they want to talk
about earlier.
When you know the Fermi paradox,
what were all the aliens if
civilization.
So likely yes.
Do you think looking at all this virtual
reality,
and this is something I explored,
I did a single podcast the other day
with just me answering questions and
somebody asks about the Fermi paradox
and it really made me think about it
even more and I've been thinking about
it since then.
Do you think it's possible that
civilizations never get to travel
through space because they get to this
thing,
they realize that the real juice is in
virtual?
Like why do you have to like physically
Trev traverse between one galaxy to
another when you could figure out a way
through technology and ultimately
through artificial intelligence creating
infinitely more complex artificial
reality that we're going to never
travel,
all of our travel is going to be done
internally.
Well,
yeah,
I do.
I think that that that is a great
response to the Fermi paradox.
And I think that um,
w w our addiction to the idea that we
are our body is going to be something
that fades away over time and that we
stop having this concept that I'm
localized in my,
that my visit there.
You know,
we live in a world where people believe
that all they are is their body.
They think I am my physical body.
That's it.
That's what I am.
That's the sum total of meat inside,
outside,
inside,
body,
outside,
everything else.
Even though what we were talking about
earlier,
we know that we're inextricably woven in
to the fabric of every single thing.
So really your body is one part of the
infinite universe and right now you have
become completely fixated on it.
You think it's you.
So vr,
you put vr on first thing that happens,
which is one of my favorite things is
you'll hold your,
you'll hold your hand up in front of
your face,
right?
And if you have the htc vive,
you'll see their amazing controllers is
floating in the air.
But then you'll look down.
There's no fucking body there,
man.
You're looking down and it's just a
blank space.
You don't have a body anymore.
Now when someone touches you in Vr,
it's really fucking cool because you
don't see him.
It's like a ghost is touching you,
and I'm not saying I've done this,
but if you were to have sex in Vr,
you've done it.
Never Joe,
have you done?
We'll never have sex out of wedlock.
But if you were to have sex in Vr,
then suddenly you don't have a body
anymore.
Okay,
but you're having sex in vr with another
person.
Who's your vr with another person?
Physical sex with someone.
And what do you see on the other side?
It depends on what you decided to be
having sex.
And so you could,
you get up sex with your girlfriend and
pretend it's like the cookie monster.
You could have sex with your girlfriend
and just be laying a on in some field
looking up at the stars.
Cookie Monster's feet up in the air like
bugs bunny and you're banging in the
ass.
Here's what's weird,
man.
This is what's really weird and no one
understands it.
But with Vr,
apparently people have tried it for some
reason they can't do that.
There's no way to bring the cookie
monster to fuck the cookie monster.
Put a man on the moon.
We could fuck the cookie monster.
Absolutely man,
you could.
You could do that.
You could definitely do that.
But,
but it's,
it's kind of like something about the
philosophical implications of not having
a body.
Even if it's being induced by
technology.
I'm sure you've taken a high enough dose
of something where you merge into the
universe and you feel like you don't
have a self anymore.
You should.
It become,
so to imagine being able to induce that
with Vr so that now you've removed the
thing that you've been identifying with
your entire life.
Your body is yourself and there's just a
blank space.
Yet consciousness remains.
Even though you know you have a body
under,
when you take the goggles off,
you know it's there.
As time passes,
when you're wearing this shit,
you begin to forget about there.
You're going to forget about the
external world.
And,
and when you finally do take the goggles
off,
it's like,
oh,
oh fuck,
oh right,
this is my office.
This is,
it's the same
thing that happens in some ways when you
get in a tank,
when you're in the tank with no vr
technology,
you sometimes have experiences where you
go into like a dream state and you think
things are happening that aren't really
happening and then you wake up out of
them and you're in the tank,
right.
And they happen in a crazy,
vivid way.
You don't have any sensory input.
You're not,
you're not feeling that.
Like if you have a dream,
you're still feeling the bed most of the
time.
Like you're out of that stage and you're
in this dream dimension.
But if for some reason you moved a
little bit and you hit your pillow or
your,
your foot touch the nightstand or
something like that,
you're going to snap out of it.
We ain't that God damn tank.
You don't feel anything.
Yeah.
You're flying through space already.
That's it.
So you can almost like use that as a
homemade virtual reality thing.
Absolutely.
But the ability to program is where
things get squirrely.
Yeah.
The ability to create any sort of
scenario you would like.
Yeah.
It's the best.
It's going to have so many therapeutic
uses.
What haptic feedback.
Yeah,
man,
it's big.
It's,
it's like haptic.
So like,
you know,
one impossible end result could be full
bodied haptic suits in float tanks in
the float tank can go just came.
Well yeah,
it's,
it's one,
it's one of the potential uses of the
thing.
I mean fuck yeah.
All the,
there's just so much like just there's
just so much it's going to be able to,
it's going to have,
I mean,
one thing I really hope people do is,
um,
and I was thinking about doing this man,
but like I always think about doing
things like this,
I never do it.
So maybe one of you guys out there,
I'll do it as like bringing this shit
old senior citizens homes and letting
people who haven't experienced it who
are maybe like not going to be in this
dimension much longer,
have a chance to like Susan if you see
what's going on because I think that'd
be a great service for people.
People who are like,
uh,
paraplegics and hospitals to bring this
technology to them and to let them
experience,
you know,
the freedom for a little while if they
can find that their hospital rooms when
you,
there's so many weirdly anti vr people,
man,
even counting them.
I haven't seen anybody,
dude.
I was at,
uh,
well,
you know,
people are like,
Ugh,
vr.
I've already heard that.
Like,
you know,
it's gonna.
It's gonna.
It's like a,
it's like three d tv,
that kind of shit.
People have new students to this.
Just some Dick at a party.
There's no point talking about it.
I was trying to impress a girl.
There was no girl around maybe trying to
fuck you.
I fucked him.
Okay.
Did you take your three year old is
really big.
You should nagging me.
But he was trying to like,
yeah,
he's probably uh,
trying to uh,
prod you or he didn't like the fact
you're smarter than him.
It's,
I don't know if I was,
but I'll tell you,
it's going to be,
it's going to be one of the most
powerful therapeutic tools,
uh,
that that's ever existed.
Just what it,
what it's going to be able to do just
for like,
you know,
you hear about,
there was a great,
I think it was a vice article,
I can't remember which article about a
guy who has to program the music that
people listen to during the mushroom,
uh,
studies that they're doing.
Like what playlist do you play for
someone who's undergoing psychedelic
therapy?
Right?
But for this tool,
for psychedelic therapy,
like the ability to,
there's a program,
Oh my God,
when you come over,
I can't wait to show you this.
It's called sound self sound self.
And what it is is you put these goggles
on and headphones that have a microphone
on and you chant into the thing,
right?
So you're like,
oh,
and it's true.
It takes,
that's it.
I mean,
again,
this stuff is,
it takes that responds to your sounds
are making and then plays it back
through your headphones.
So you're hear your voice being
transformed and replaced is like deeper
or lower.
It's just very psychedelic
and you're watching the images while
you're hearing your voice that's being
altered.
It's like you're doing rounds.
How many people are going to be saying
that?
What's this guy's video?
So we could get them some views.
What does it say?
OCULUS rift games.
Sound self virtual reality.
Guinea pigs.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
God Damn.
And that's something if you,
if you guys out there,
I haven't,
oh my God,
look at that.
Well,
let's just,
yeah,
let's explain where we were watching
were watching as these crazy three
dimensional computer animations that
look like they look like psychedelic
trips.
It looks like almost like a gate,
whatnot,
dmt itself,
but like a gateway to dmt.
Like right before you blow through.
Like there's a moment,
there's a moment where you see like what
I think what they described as the
flower of life before you blast on
through to the other side.
Now,
uh,
for those of you have an htc vive,
if you want to use this game,
uh,
you can,
you can pay for the alpha.
It's 30 bucks cause goggles with the
eyeballs and then you've got to use
something called the revive injector to
get it to run.
Anyone who has a five out there,
I'll know what I'm talking about cause
like
what is the difference between a,
sorry to interrupt you but what does it
different sheen,
oculus rift and the vive.
So unfortunately oculus has created,
has made a bunch of deals with the
developers to make exclusive content for
the Oculus.
Right.
And oculus is great,
it's really cool.
But that was Oculus Oculus,
but it's not as good as the vibe for a
few different reasons.
Uh,
one of the reasons is the vive is
designed for being able to walk around.
The vibe comes with these and maybe the
rift you can do it but it seems like
it's more localized.
But the Mo and I said,
forgive me by the way,
Oculus rift people,
I love you,
carmax.
Coming on soon.
I had the dk one,
I had the dk two,
you know John Carmack from again
software.
He's,
he's an oculus rift now.
Oculus is great and,
and God bless you guys for making vr
possible because they were the ones of
Palmer luckey ran with this fucking
torch.
He like made this fucking happen.
The only problem is the oculus released
without controllers like vive has.
Right.
And that was a big mistake.
So the boxing thing that we saw,
that was vibe,
that was five,
but oculus is releasing controllers now.
And honestly,
now that I'm getting so sucked into Vr,
I've actually considered buying an
oculus rift just so I have both.
But you don't Christ,
dude,
you're deep.
You don't really need it because you
can,
um,
use a something called revive,
which allows you to play Oculus Games on
the HTC vive.
You're so deep in this man.
It's weird to see.
It's the coolest fucking thing.
Just says this is the same.
Yeah.
Dock.
And that was terrified of everquest and
world of warcraft and all that other
shit that you got sucked into.
You're not terrified of this.
You're a,
you're just a whole hog diving right in
here.
It feels right.
I love that expression.
It feels like the right thing.
It feels like,
and it's cool.
I'll tell you,
man,
by the way,
there's not a lot of people right now
who have vr gear and there's just some
kind of like exciting thing about same
floor ground floor and being like,
oh my God,
this is going to change the world.
Let's do a podcast.
I'm from your place.
Let's do your podcast does.
Friday,
Doug and I are doing the Ice House in
Pasadena on Friday night.
We're doing the eight o'clock show.
Sold out.
Sorry.
Um,
but we're going to do,
we'll do a podcast from your house and
we'll do it with me experiencing your vr
for the first time and we'll keep
barbecued.
I will try to things we were so high
before the show.
I was worried if I was going to be able
to pull it.
Man,
that breath spray paint,
playing around.
I was worried.
I was like,
oh no.
I went,
God,
I don't know if I can handle this one
dude.
I did a podcast with Sam Harris and I
took 12 shots of the breast spray for
the podcast.
I wanted to see what would happen.
And I kept going.
And halfway to the podcast I was like,
oh my God.
It was like I was skiing down a hill.
Like on,
I was on a black diamond ski course.
I was,
I was up and I was moving and I was
conscious and I knew just keep,
just keep paying attention to the road.
Liz left and right and left and right.
You're gonna,
you're gonna make it,
you're going to make it.
You don't make it.
Where do you get Jambo from?
Don't say the name out loud.
Yeah.
It's a girl has no name.
I'm sorry,
girl has no name.
She doesn't,
but I don't want to say it three times.
Like candy man in front of the mirror.
We'll talk
Friday night.
You mother fuckers.
So,
uh,
we'll be doing an episode of the Duncan
trussell family hour chat with the Ice
House upon my pleasure,
my brother.
I'll always love doing these.
We need to do these more often.
You know,
we're really good friends,
but we see each other and getting it,
get deeper with each other during these
podcasts than we ever do in real life
now.
Because if we,
in real life,
we would be talking to other people.
We'd be looking at our phone,
we'd be doing some other shit now
eating.
I love these moments,
Joe.
There are some of the happiest moments
in my life,
so,
so grateful you let
me be on the show.
If I'm grateful that you're on it,
man.
But what I wanted to say was,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing because I never
would have imagined that we would get to
know each other better and deeper and
more intensely by doing podcasts
together with a whole world could hear
it.
I mean,
you and I have had some crazy fucking
conversations alone in private with
just,
you and I are just talk to you about
stuff for hours and hours,
but there's something crazy about doing
these like this,
and we're doing our live and then we put
them out there.
They're,
they're fascinating,
man.
We got to do it more often.
Uh,
all right,
we'll be back tomorrow with a Wayne
Fetterman,
my friend Wayne Fetterman.
Very funny.
Standup comic.
Neal Brennan's coming.
Uh,
it's,
it looked like it was going to be Gary
Johnson and Stan hope on Thursday,
but it,
Gary Johnson might have to pull out.
He got to fly into Wednesday.
He's doing a town hall meeting on CNN,
which is big news because he's a third
party candidate.
That's what happens.
People get sick of the two parties.
All right.
But,
uh,
we'll be back soon.
See Ya.
Bye.
Yeah.